chinese state media
threatened that china the pla would
shoot down nancy pelosi's plane if she
tried going to taiwan
and chinese state media is ccp which is
effectively their government so i didn't
want to put a headline being like china
literally said they do it it's chinese
news that's saying they're going to do
it but it's basically the propaganda
mouthpiece for the chinese communist
party maybe it's all bluster but
pelosi's trip to taiwan is uh well it's
shaken things up the u.s has redeployed
a strike group into the south china sea
so naturally tensions are hot and maybe
it's meaningless maybe it'll just be
more bluster or maybe it's out of
something serious because i don't know
there is conversation about the fourth
turning we got that to talk about we
also got the house just passed
an assault weapons ban now it's expected
to go
to just collapse in the senate 50 50. so
we'll see and there's the filibusters
it's not going to go anywhere we'll talk
about that and then um tucker carlson
oh tucker
he said he wants to rename or no he
literally said he did a poll and they
renamed monkey pox to schlong coven
well everybody's mad they're saying
tucker is homophobic for doing it a lot
of people find it funny we'll talk all
about that before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member if you would like to help
support our work and get access to our
uncensored after hours show and in that
i will lightly address a little bit
about last night
um simply put
a guess that's something that you can't
say that's it's just it's that simple uh
i posted on youtube the issue was
youtube censorship censorship policies
we took the show down there's a an
hour-long members only show where we
talk about a ton of things not just that
i don't want people to think that the
full explanation is
just the members only but the issue is
well i can't repeat what was said
we try to avoid highlighting these
things we don't put targets on our back
but i know that people want some kind of
explanation so we are
exacerbating the problem by addressing
it live but that's a reality and um
you know i'll just say
uh
for people wondering you know like why
don't you just go live again or why not
it's like okay well after the show goes
down
we have to figure out what's going on
with the guests but to figure out where
they're going what we're going to do
and
considering the volatility of everything
i was just like we're not just going to
restart this because
you know
well i mean i'll put it this way
every guest is given the the walkthrough
of like
look this is a live show broadcast to
hundreds of thousands of people reaching
over a million people every night and
you need to treat what you say like you
would any other live show and i think
because of the relaxed nature of it some
people don't and so i'll just you know
fully come out and say it like it's been
a stressful couple of weeks and having
that happen i was just like ready to
pass out right here and so when we did
the members only segment it's because
people pay for a members only segment
i'm not going to not deliver that for
people who have already paid with a lot
of members and it was it was really
chill and easy just like to riff and if
you watch the members only thing you'll
see me basically just venting about the
stresses that we're dealing with so uh
you know long story short
if someone comes on the show and you
know we give everybody like a 10 minute
spiel about like
you like here are the things that you
will get knocked down for here's how you
know
like
that we're not saying
for the most part like don't say things
you know like we even tell people
they're allowed to swear just try not to
but if someone comes out and overtly
says something and there's nothing i can
do about it it's just like okay so
here's what we're gonna do
we uh because we're idiots we actually
don't have this but we should like any
other live show
there's normally uh
a simple app
that creates a lag between
the video as it's recorded and then what
goes live and all the producers to do is
just press the button and it just snips
the frames so if someone says something
super egregious
like a threat they can just press a
button and then it just disappears and
the show keeps going so that's what
we're working on and truth be told
something we should have had a long time
ago but we're like i don't know just
winging it this whole time in case you
haven't realized so uh that's that's the
me addressing to the best of my
abilities we we go into greater detail
and the members only thing but only
because we're kind of venting it was it
was brett dasavik it was uh andy who's
our cto and us just kind of talking
about life and stuff and uh is what it
is i suppose but we're gonna talk about
news and also we're talking the
apocalypse because vegas flooded
and there's apocalypse talk uh we can we
can have so joining us tonight is ben
stewart
what's up everybody ben stewart you can
go to benjosefstewart.com where i
give you the news but i also get into
alternative topics such as mind-bending
practices psychedelics and alternative
history so go over to benjoffstewart.com
i also on my youtube channel ben joseph
stewart
you can find a put out weekly news show
and
do thursdays
podcast 5 pm eastern every thursday live
with some amazing people all the way
from ufc fighters to people in the
psychedelic movement so
check it out right now awesome to be
back lauren's back i am i'm back you
know who i am lauren southern also known
by the audience uh hopefully lovingly as
paper cup happy girl but we drank it all
with dead last night so tonight drink it
all all of it at the paper cup bar we're
going to be having some patron grand
patron grand patron not just patron and
we're going to be mixing manuka honey in
it we're getting fancy over here at the
paper cup that's 600 honey yes
lauren's like how how expensive can i
make a paper cup drink and i was like
well that cost six hundred dollars
we're going to keep up in the ante every
show
i would say i i feel like honey in grand
patron probably would be really good i
think it's going to be good i might mix
you a paper cup too here you can do that
and i will take it yes it is
from the paper you said manuka honey is
not the best tasting
it's bitter yeah it's like it's like
expensive imported australian medicinal
honey that is like the most medicinal uh
manuka i've ever seen and it's also the
bitterest so you've got the so you take
this rectally right oh gosh absolutely
what you're telling me is i'm making
myself a health drink yes that's what
i'm getting well actually alcohol my
understanding is in in small amounts is
good for you with lowest cortisol
uh
so
you know i wonder if this is going to be
um good for me after we did that legal
like heroin medicine that you made me
have today nad nad whatever that was we
hooked lauren up to the nad
and she was groaning and screaming that
was honestly the most painful thing i've
ever done in my life it hurts
easily it's up there what was it how
would you explain the feeling well tim
said it was going to be like period pain
which i don't know no i didn't say that
that was not me
i said if that's what period pain is
y'all got nothing to complain about no
oh yeah no it's way worse and i don't
know how you weren't you were playing
video games the whole time as i couldn't
even move but i was oh and you know what
okay you guys need to understand this
tim just sends me a message saying hey
want to do nad on twitter and i have no
idea what it is and i thought it was
like a show or something that he started
and i didn't want to be like oh i don't
know what that is so i just said cool
yeah sure man you got it buddy yeah you
got it i show up and they have like
needles everywhere and a nurse
everywhere
what is happening here little do i know
i'm about to be hooked up to an actual
torture device for two hours
groaning oh my gosh i don't know how you
do that man and and and i gotta i gotta
i'm sorry lauren but you went slow
like rogan talks about how he cranks it
up to full full speed
and slams it in 20 minutes so for those
aren't familiar it's nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide it's like it's what
your body turns b vitamins into and it's
like it's like a
it's like a rejuvenation thing you can
get and joe rogan talks about it quite a
bit apparently he like smokes pot and
then just cranks it all the way up but
it's painful so they give you
painkillers
i s my explanation is it feels like you
turned around and there's a bear like
that feeling you get when an adrenaline
rush hits you that but for like an hour
and a half or two hours it's
excruciating yeah it feels like the top
of the roller coaster when you're going
down and it's for two hours doesn't stop
and your whole stomach is just doing
that churn thing repeatedly i have never
i can really remember any points in my
life where i've like yelled at a nurse
and being like stop it no no
stop
you went you were like crank it up and
the nurse was like no i don't want to do
that you were like do it
and she was like i'll do it a little bit
and then you went
you gotta know and then lauren was like
are there only two settings zero and 100
i actually had like a proper panic
attack when i saw her leave because i
can't move like i like literally
couldn't move my body and i'm like i'm
gonna be trapped in this hell and she's
gone and there's no one that can turn
this down
dude well anyway so lauren's here and
she's treating it with uh some grand
patrol
this is the funniest thing because it's
like it's a vitamin drip you get like b
vitamins and and it's like hydrating so
like afterwards i feel great we had we
had hibachi grilled meat and sushi and
lauren's like i'm gonna drink
it's uh nad is a precursor to a protein
that's called there's certains there's
these proteins your body has and the
protein measures the amount of energy in
your cell so when your cell divides this
protein these certains want to make sure
there's enough energy in both of the new
cells if there's not then they have to
clip off at the end caps of the
chromosomes to compensate and that's
what they call aging so having enough of
these proteins because of the nad as a
precursor it's a longevity thing yeah
accuracy it supposedly it reverses and
reduces aging oh yeah so you can do two
things as a rich famous person you can
torture children for ancient crime or
whatever it's called or you can do nad
so i'm pretty sure you guys can know
that tim's doing the eternal life the
proper way not killing children right
right there's a lot of research out of
harvard on it and they'll mix it with
intermittent fasting um berberine or
like what's it metformin as a diabetes
medicine but the berberine's the plant
they they derive that from and
resveratrol and they've even had
experiments on like dogs and they find
like life extension and dogs and stuff
fascinating so you look young so
lauren's here
i'm here sorry that was a very long time
moving on
i didn't get the nad about i am in
crossland also happy to be here let's
talk yeah nad is a trip i'm glad lauren
survived and we have her here with us
again tonight i'm excited to talk about
the apocalypse let's go
all right so uh over the daily mail they
reported it
let me read the headline china says it
will shoot pelosi's plane down if she
travels to taiwan under u.s fighter
escort speaker refuses to confirm trip
quote if u.s fighter jets escort pluses
planted in taiwan it is an invasion who
xi jin the commentator for the chinese
state affiliated global times wrote on
twitter the pla has the right to force
forcibly dispel policies plane and the
u.s fighter jets including firing
warning shots and making tactical
movements of obstruction if ineffective
then shoot them down who said wow plus
has not confirmed reports she will
travel to taiwan but the other news is
that the u.s has sent a carrier and a
strike group to the south china sea so
it does seem like things are escalating
a bit ladies and gentlemen it is
apocalypse night here las vegas flooded
there's like
war with china
there was an op-ed in the new york times
that said pelosi's trip to taiwan is too
dangerous
so i'm wondering if you got what do you
guys think about this i do kind of feel
like
china's bluster come on some some ccp
state media guy saying he's going to
shoot down pelosi yeah right yeah you
said at the top of the shows this is not
the ccp that said it was a it was a news
media organization no no this is the ccp
oh i thought you said it came out of the
news media it so so my point is
if you have a company in china it's the
ccp oh that i agree with yeah but this
wasn't like
this is state propaganda state
propaganda so what i want to be careful
of it's not xi jinping the government or
the millet to pla coming out and saying
we will shoot you down it's their
propaganda arm saying we have a right to
shoot at you and if if it doesn't stop
you we'll we can shoot you and they also
this says that they'll shoot at her
plane if she goes there but then later
in the thing it says we'll shoot at her
plane if she brings fighter escorts
that's a different situation if she just
goes in without escorts maybe there's
not saber rattling or or the fourth
turning
totally the fourth turning actually what
was it tony robbins just had on
who's the surviving one william strauss
or neil
theory one of them died yeah one of them
died but the other one was just talking
tony robbins and it's getting getting
kind of real in this fourth turn but
apparently it ends
20 28. it's neil how's the one that's
still alive yeah if it ends 2028 we're
in it
so i don't know 2026 is i've heard 2026
is when things are going to get
absolutely bonkers i just did a piece on
this on my youtube where um
200 i think it was glub i forget like
sir john globb
he studied empires the rise in the fall
of them and he said that 20 20 or 250
years is the maximum lifespan of a
country
united states will turn 20 uh 250 years
in 2026. so that kind of coincides with
that i even wrote down some other things
we meet all the criteria for an empire
and decline like you know massive
complexity that just seems unsustainable
supposedly climate deforestation
environmental degradation
and then changing relations between
friendlies and
and foes or or heightening tensions
between them and there's there's other
things in there oh yeah yeah yeah i mean
uh cultural collapse
uh uh wastefulness a lack of decorum i
mean like yeah decadence uh uh basement
of the currency like like imagine like a
young woman pouring expensive honey into
a paper cup with really expensive
liquors
right that shows based around decadence
what an animal and you know there's
there's one other funny thing when going
back through like uh rome all the way
through many other empires apparently in
the late stages of it
um they all seem to highlight uh chefs
they make celebrities out of their chefs
oh i read that yeah yeah it's it's just
some weird anomaly no i i yeah man i
wonder if there's like an emergent
phenomenon around
food and chefs and like so much well
you're you're so comfortable you're
entertained by
taking food to the most extreme levels
it's it's pure gluttony and then also
turning like animals into babies
like how many times have you seen little
dogs in like cradles like all dressed up
and everything that's got to be a sign
of an empire in decline yeah the chef
celebrities and baby pets i noticed like
when i watched the survival videos of
people like carving building their own
house with their axe and stuff and then
it'll cut to them like frying really
crappy spam or something in a pan and
then like cooking and eating it i'm like
this is not appetizing why is this part
of the video
of them like cutting up their meat i
guess it's like people want to know what
it's like to live out in the woods and
hunt and cook your own stuff but
that's that's like the opposite of
decline like watching a video of some
super ripped dude killing a deer and
then
eating it but it'll this will be like he
opens a can of tuna and then has some
carrots like frozen carrots and he'll be
cooking it in a pan okay so that's well
this is like chef and decline that's
post-apocalyptic yeah you know this is
like celebrity chef the real yeah that's
20 28.
is making the cakes that you can't
distinguish oh my gosh
i could cut this right now and it could
be a cake isn't that a netflix show it
is yeah are you serious have you seen
the video where the guy he's watching
the the videos of people like cutting a
shampoo bottles cake and he looks
shocked and then he like grabs his phone
and squeeze it it's cake
freaks out and then he like grabs his tv
remote squeeze it it's cake and he
starts panicking and then he looks down
at his butt and he grabs his butt in its
cake and he's like
that was really anything yeah everything
is cute everything is why why are they
highlight chefs what's up with this i i
think i think tim's on to something
there that um
i forget it wasn't john perkins it was
somebody else that was saying like
there's this feeling in whether it's a
nation or an empire that like times were
great we were great but no one's feeling
it anymore like there's there's another
one mercenaries when you have to start
fighting you know hiring mercenaries for
fighting your wars for you
like the the god and country isn't
working anymore
then and same thing with the bread and
circuses i think it's part of the whole
chef thing as part of the bread and
circuses thing did you see that they're
having serious problems recruiting
people for the military they've lowered
the education standard they've lowered
the fitness standard we're gonna have
worse fought by mercenaries in no time
yeah i i wouldn't doubt that actually
what's interesting i was in the military
from 2000 to 2006
and everyone that uh like when i got
basically to my unit everyone was saying
like yeah you know you kind of went
through the you know the
the piece of cake boot camp where they
can't touch you they can't hit you they
can't push you and like you didn't need
to do you know even half as much of the
running as we needed to so even back
then about 20 years ago
apparently it was like a
a shell of what it used to be boot camp
interesting we had blackwater fighting a
huge part or at least if not fighting
the war in the middle east they were
like functioning as administration for a
lot of i mean that's mercenary well look
look at ukraine
american citizens are on the ground in
ukraine but the u.s is like we didn't
send them there right they're not
officially ours and it's like an
international cohort of
individuals fighting this war but so you
said countries got 250 years but what
about like france which had 900 000
years
well it's empires it's not countries
it's empires so like other empires are
still around you know other like great
britain
still around you know but has the u.s
been an empire for 250 years it hasn't
well not not an empire and that's a good
point because uh 17 i don't i don't know
when they start the clock either right
when you are officially an empire
because i know 1776
i guess you wouldn't have called the
united states an empire you know it
wasn't it wasn't until i think like the
1900s that the u.s went totally
empirical
i mean yeah
46 even who is that who is that guy that
everybody hates woodrow wilson oh man
yeah everybody hates that guy right it
really it was like after world war ii
they realized if we don't become a world
order um
empire whatever that we're gonna have
world war three so they were like
liberal economic order which you could
call an empire um we got military bases
all over the earth sign up the liberal
international economy yes the lie the
lie was established in 1946 it's it's
also this is a different world than all
the other empires when we were you know
like mapping out this 250 year life span
as well where i mean when you're talking
about nations and empires you're also
talking about like major economic blocks
like transnational economic blocks i
also want to point out
isn't it that empires last 250 years on
average
is it well i mean the soviet union
lasted 69 years
yeah and that was massive i mean they
were spreading all over the planet
remnants still exist in some fashion
today
the u.s
i mean i wonder if the 250 years thing
is is based upon
the extent of communications without
electronics
right so all of these big empires
communicated through letter delivery
carrier horseback
now we have rapid communication that
causes things to evolve much more
quickly
especially now with the internet and
social media it's just ramping up faster
than
so i mean you think about uh franz
ferdinand right
he gets shot how long did it take for
everyone to find out
probably not that long relative to now
but it was lightning speed relative to
previous conflicts
telegraph radio word went out to their
countries really quickly but how long
did it take for regular people to find
out you know if we had something like
that happen today it'd be on social
media
the moment it happened everyone would
see it so it's even faster that that
anger that animosity
the conflict can spread instantly across
across every person so you think about
the conflicts we've had in this country
sentiment for civil war right in the
united states how long did it take for
an idea to go from one person to
everyone in a city to make it from new
york to you know illinois or to you know
down to florida like those ideas to
change and then create rifts probably
took a really really long time well you
look at like the first persian empire
and one of the biggest reasons they
collapsed internally was because of all
of these internal rifts they were having
rebellions they were taking slaves and
bringing them into their military and
making them mercenaries as we were
talking about and now because of
technology like you're saying we're
having this ramping up of that kind of
stuff and rebellions like black lives
matter internally
causing rebellion within the u.s all of
these and then we also have information
that shows us that you have russia china
potentially pumping money into these
internal rebellions that we're facing in
the west and you're right we're gonna
have basically a repeat
of what caused a lot of these past
empires to collapse on crack because of
the technological
fentanyl yeah it's the waiting i can't
stand
yeah yeah just bring it home
ian's talking about a guy in the woods
like cracking open an old can of tuna
and putting carrots in it i'm like
sounds pretty good
i can't wait i wonder if this is
actually an american empire or if it's
just the british empire and masked with
the american military because
that's part of there's actually an
empire that's part of it there's also
like a math equation this one guy it was
an old ted talks but he was saying like
even in a back uh bacterial petri dish
uh dish mismatches between resources and
consumption
cause
things like five generations in before
the or before the decline um it's the
population is doubling every single uh
generation and then five generations
before the decline um the food declines
by 15 16. the next generation by
three-fourths um and it's empty in the
next generation uh or in the next
generation is about half and then the
following generation is the mathematical
conclusion of it i don't know if that if
that petri dish is a one-on-one parallel
to what we're dealing with but well so
you've heard that wealth lasts three
generations they say right the first
generation
is you know comes up figures it out
works hard and then has that within them
this individual they have kids those
kids learn a lesson from the the first
generation they inherit the wealth and
they know a little bit enough to kind of
just sort of maintain it
now you have another generation and
they're learning a lesson about a lesson
it's it's a copy of a copy and so by the
third generation they're they have no
idea how the empire was built they have
no idea how to start a company they
don't have the same life lessons
so i have to think about this too
you know i hear stories about people who
they're like i was a college dropout and
i was poor and i worked hard and then
now they have kids and those kids are
children of the wealthiest people on the
planet they're not going to learn the
same lesson
like steve jobs was homeless he was like
sleeping on couches and floors
and then he was he had that fire within
him and ruthlessness let's be real
his kids you know i don't know i'm
assuming he has kids but like the
children of these people don't have that
they grew up in luxury
totally i know it's like such a tired
analogy the good men bad times thing but
they've got another arab parable that's
like just like what you're talking about
where it's like i'll ride a camel my son
will ride will ride in a toyota his son
will ride in a ferrari and then his son
will ride a camel and there's a reason
that these parables exist though the
good men hard times whatever it's
because it's just what happens every
damn time and humanity keeps trying to
tell us we've lived this story a billion
times but all right guys good luck do it
again have fun that's why i'm saying
like
when i have kids
like
i'm gonna kick them out at three years
old and be like
here's a bandana a trowel a pack of
seeds and a pointy stick
maybe a match if you don't know but in
all seriousness what we do is we take
the newborn we put him in the woods for
a day and if he survives he's strong
enough to join the truck that's true i
think that's something george
no no that was the spartans i think they
did that right if the baby didn't
survive like out in the wilderness it
wasn't strong enough
and then you know nothing crazy like
that but i certainly think you gotta
teach
i mean like hard labor like good manual
labor chores lifting stuff shoveling
mowing the lawn you gotta teach kids
you know those kind of lessons
why is he trying to does the cat get to
join the show
it's because ian started giving him
water and now he's coming on the show
every time i'm getting some let's
let's let's pull up this next story here
and talk about the decline we got this
from timcast.com
u.s house passes first assault weapons
ban since 1994.
laughable
stupid and a waste of time and
apparently some republicans even joined
in to support the democrats banning
nothing
bill makes no sense no one knows yeah so
i think this is a really good example
not of disarmament right a lot of people
are saying they're trying to you know i
think luke tweeted this they're gonna
try and disarm you for their
depopulation agenda or something and i'm
like no
i think it's it's nonsense it's
logicless they're not doing anything
this bill
bans half
it'll like thomas massey pointed this
out the mini 14 receiver is banned but
the mini receiver mini 14 receiver is
also not banned in the same bill
and and verbatim so massey points out
the mini 14 with a pistol grip and a
collapsing stock is an assault weapon so
it's banned the receiver of any such
weapon is also banned but the mini 14
with a rifle stock is not banned and the
receiver and his weapon is not banned
and so he points out he's like so how is
the identical receiver both banned and
not banned and they have no answer they
literally just don't answer it it's all
political moves it's like obviously i'm
in canada but right after you had the
shooting in texas at the school trudeau
came out and banned um transfer and sale
of handguns or proposed a ban the next
day and it's like
why you're we're talking about a
shooting in another country using a gun
that's already banned in our country and
you're going to put a freeze on sale of
a handgun that are rarely used for
shootings in canada at all where we
don't have a problem with this
completely political and it seems like
the us are doing that too even though
sometimes i feel like you guys have
better laws around guns better
understanding and then every time i
think that your politicians go into
stuff like this i just gotta say it
every time trudeau does a press
conference he's it sounds like he's
trying like he's talking to somebody
he's about to rape
but i'm not trying to be like when he
was like
we need to ban all the guns it's like
it's it's the voice someone has when
they're grabbing them and like just
relax
let me do this put down the weapon
yeah i'm taking your gun away from you
and then and then it's funny because you
guys you guys up in canada banned guns
like around the same time it was like
uvaldi right
trudeau announces their freezing handgun
sales and it was obvious it was a
response to a u.s news story but he also
had previously complained up in canada
that canada with a trucker protest is
that american politics are seeping into
canada oh so true yeah and then he comes
out and it's like come on dude spare me
i think this assault weapons ban is
a perfect example of what the democrats
are they will they they they have no
logic to their to their morals it's like
we're all trying to figure out what is
what are the rules and how do we live
together
among the democrats and most of the left
it's just pure tribalism
so they're like we're banning guns
excellent does it make sense who cares
as long as you agree with thing
current thing current year currently if
there's a bill that is proposing to both
ban and not ban something you've got to
discard that stupid bill or at least
remove that section from the bill before
you can move forward you can't even vote
yes or no on something like that it's
going to be really funny when someone
gets arrested with a mini 14 receiver
and then they like sue and they're like
well
what's the logic there is the logic that
if it says it's not banned but then it
says it is bad therefore it is banned
you know what i mean like the negative
is stronger than the positive or
something how does that how does this
even work
i don't think they care yeah
no i want to point something out too
because um i think we have this tweet
from ian let me see if i can find it i
don't know where it's at yeah here we go
this is perfectly in line with what
we're talking about check this out
ron filippowski
what was the name philip kowski
says lauren bobert wants the house to
pass a rule to give her five days to
read a bill before voting on it
he didn't say much after that
he just said this thing
but you'll notice a lot of the comments
are people saying like this is
ridiculous
i can you know i can read a book in a
day
but then ian chimed in
ian of course you should read it it's
your tweet yeah it should be a felony
for congressmen to vote on a bill they
have not read i want them under oath
acknowledging they've read the bill
before voting yeah interestingly when
ian chimed in with that one then you get
some unity everyone's like yeah actually
that makes sense but the crazy thing to
me is
there are so many people responding to
ron philipkowski
just making fun of lauren bobert for for
saying something that is quite possibly
the most logical and bipartisan thing
ever
yeah i was actually very pleased with
the response to this because like ron
has a ukraine flag in his profile so
there was a part of me that was like oh
geez should i just assume he's some
zealot and it's like you know what what
he said is just neutral i'm going to
respond neutrally and then people in the
comments you see people with ukraine
flags saying yes this is actually a
great idea you see people that are like
i'm a christian conservative this is a
great idea like i said in their profile
so it's just a it's an american idea and
i think it's an idea that that justifies
or that supports like
liberty
uh you cannot have ignorance in jordan's
race
i mean that's just it's just absolutely
at least five days at least i'm shocked
that that wasn't a rule beforehand like
the idea that they're passing these
absolutely critical rules for your
country and it's like not even a few
days to decompress and think about it
maybe they can read it in one day great
can they think about it and really weigh
the moral consequences of the stuff
they're putting into your nation it's
worse than you realize because marjorie
taylor green pointed out to us there's a
giant cat butthole on the camera by the
way marjorie what a good job buddy
marjorie taylor green pointed out that
often times when they're passing bills
they don't even
have anybody in the room it'll be like
three democrats and three republicans
and someone who's not even the speaker
will be like oh we got a bill here it
says this and they go
oh it passes and so what they've been
doing is the freedom caucus has like a
watch where they go down and call it
they they call for like a roll call vote
or something where they got to force all
the members of congress to come back in
and actually vote on these bills
actually do their jobs yeah but they're
still not reading them that's the crazy
thing
absolutely unconscionable and people
have pointed out in this twitter thread
as well that this is something that
should have been enshrined in the
constitution from day one just assumed
that they would be reading the bills
because that was their intention was
like what how could they never how could
they not you know i would like to see a
i don't know if you guys have any
knowledge of like if you could compare
you know the beginning of the u.s how
many bills were being proposed and
passed at the start versus now i reckon
it's like a mass ramp up stuff because
it's super easy to just like roll out
that rug right oh we can just pass and
do things every single day but it's
super hard to roll it back and i don't
think things were initially like the
constitution was put in place for a
country operating like this where it's
like adhd let's just pass things and
propose things all over the place every
day and not even think about it and have
this 24-hour news cycle where it's like
bam bam bam bam bam they'll also put
like a thousand things in one bill yeah
so they'll call it the money they have
less bills now than they used to but
that's because they've got 500 times the
amount of stuff in each bill yeah but
let's let's go back to what uh you know
we're talking about a moment ago the
collapse of an empire
there there's there's certainly no
country when the members of congress are
more concerned with fundraising phone
calls than reading the bills laws are
being passed that no one even knows
about the the omnibus spending bill gets
brought in in a like a like a wagon like
it's like a red
they brought it in like a wagon 5000
pages
so when your country's doing that uh
i'll put it this way
ladies and gentlemen
our members of congress don't read the
bills
they're not there to vote on the bills
there's a porous southern border so
first
we have no legislation they're not
actually doing their job
next
we have no country a nation with no
border is not a country that's how
that's how country has to find a nation
with defined borders a nation is a is a
a group of people with shared history
culture and laws
we don't have shared laws anymore some
states have disregarded half the laws
sanctuary city sanctuary states i got to
tell you i don't i think the u.s is
basically like someone took a figurative
mountain and just splattered it all over
the place and now it's a big random
hodgepodge of nonsense
so i mean look the constitution is
switched swiss cheese
our politicians don't do their jobs the
democrats are calling supreme court
illegitimate even though they're
functioning as the constitution dictates
doesn't matter
none of it matters did you see how
they're shipping um illegal immigrants
they've been bussing illegal immigrants
from the southern border to dc and other
big cities and they just called in the
national guard in d.c
miriam bowser is it miriam muriel bowser
requested the uh the national guard to
so there's like 4 000 immigrants when i
was in tapachula i was meeting with a
few immigrants that had been deported
after a few years in dc in the states
because a lot of them have their court
cases in dc so they know yeah i'll cross
the border and i might get kicked out
because i have no standing i'm i don't
even qualify as an economic migrant i
don't qualify as anything
but they know that they'll have to be
taken to dc to hear whatever case they
have for a few years and they'll get to
have a good time there this one guy i
was speaking to was trying to get in
saying he was attacked by gangs but
half of them are actually part of gangs
and just try to use a bad experience
they had with ms-13 despite being a part
of it to get in and he's like yep i'm
making my way back up again at least
i'll get to spend a few years in dc you
know waiting on my trial will be fun you
know i'll get some food and board good
time
i can't be mad about this because the
cat crawled in my lap and so i'm just
i'm you know peace yeah it's like
the story should be really disconcerting
and distressing but i just you kind of
look like dr evil though
someone said
good evening mr bond yeah i've been
expecting you
yeah people more cats adopt a cat one
thing that's really interesting to look
at
um beyond cat conversations
one thing that's really interesting to
look at is there's i think it's the
syracuse institute that cover it the
level of what judges allow migrants in
versus which ones don't you can look at
some of the comparisons and there'll be
some judges that accept like 99 of
applicants and some that reject 99 and
only accept one percent it is actually
just a game of luck it's like going to a
freaking casino whether you're gonna get
in or not um you can compare like female
judges to male judges which county
they're in and it is has almost nothing
to do with the application that these
migrants put in or illegals put in and
everything to do with the judge's
feelings will there be people that come
and try and get legal or recourse they
get denied and then they just come back
and try to go to addition to get a
different judge basically and they can
get it in the next time i'm concerned
because what is the the solution obvi
like globalization on some level
is functionable you know we're
expansionist by nature i think expanding
liberal democracy americanism whatever
the us constitution could be good but
like how do you defend
i know one way to defend a border that
the the romans tried i mean it used to
be pretty brutal and that's not soldiers
yeah yeah weaponry like carrie lake is
talking about sending the national guard
down to the border
declaring uh an emergency uh an invasion
let me pull up the story here we got
this from nbc washington uh ian just
mentioned a moment ago dc mayor requests
national guard to help with migrants
bust to capital
a lot of people are laughing about it
saying it's like it's irony it's funny
or texas and arizona's plan is working
let me tell you something
texas and arizona could be bussing the
migrants back to where they came from to
their home countries sending them to dc
is helping the democrats in the bite
administration with their immigration
agenda
they are basically saying
so so texas is like we're going to send
these migrants to you dc and then dc is
like thanks for the help we're going to
then distribute you know these people
around the country where we see fit what
this means is we don't live that's true
the way it's supposed to work you get in
line and say i'd like to come to this
amazing country we say let us figure it
out and give you the best possible place
so that everybody thrives what the
democrats and the bite administration
are doing is they're saying
just let everybody come in and then
we'll sort them out later no rules no
rules rules and then texas in arizona
are like
we'll show you biden we'll actually pay
for the buses to send them into the
country
and then people are laughing about it
and i'm like dude you're just helping
them
they have texas and arizona could more
easily it is it is a longer bus ride to
dc
i feel like people on the right are
being duped into thinking that plan was
a good plan
there's a few things i'm not so sure how
it applies here but i know when i was
covering migration issues in europe one
thing all the migrants would do is they
would destroy their passports before
coming in and touching ground in any
european country because they had
basically been told well if you don't
have a passport they don't know where
they can deport you to
and so there are some tactics that
migrants will use to try to prevent
deportation so i'm not sure how
difficult it is for these states to do
that um if they are trying to apply
legally to get in but don't have
standing it would be much easier to
deport them but then if they're going in
and like claiming asylum status there
still has to be some sort of court case
which is the problem because they still
have to be held somewhere our goodwill
is being taken advantage of yeah people
who are coming here are not asylum
seekers they're economic migrants
i get it i i i'll tell you this i have
infinitely more respect for them for
than than the modern american leftist
that hates this country but there still
has to be a process for the sake of
maintaining what this country is if it's
good and i mean our economy is not so
good these days but still better than
other places well then there's a reason
why it is because there's a system in
place if people just come in just start
ripping apart that system you know it's
the decline of empire i mean actually
wasn't the roman empire dealing with uh
immigration
it was the it was the fall of the empire
it was all the northern uh tri like i
don't know who was it the uh not the
vandals people in the northeast but
basically
after the the empire had spread all
throughout the eastern and the western
roman empires the the empire split in
half they but then it's just like over
the next 200 years people just kept
pouring across the border and then they
would set up their new government like
their foreign government in rome in the
roman territory then all of a sudden you
realize it's not roman territory anymore
because it's that other government is
now
running the show rome also had like
bureaucratic complexity that wasn't
sustainable past a certain point and
part of that is sound familiar yeah and
kind of what you're talking about like
when you're saying the culture is part
of what holds people together that's
that's like the story it's the
agreed-upon story it also lends into why
at first you don't need to hire
mercenaries because the story is strong
and people believe it and then after a
while when you get a certain critical
mass of burn it down this this place
doesn't you know people in the country
disrespecting the story of of the very
country or the nation that's when it
starts to come apart is when the belief
that this is even a good thing that
we're upholding
and then what you were just mentioning
about like at the beginning of the
nation
how many bills were being passed well it
also feels like that the constitution
was there to say like this is what the
government is and and that's it
right and then it just kept growing and
growing and growing and then a lot of
people they need to secure their you
know position
so
keep passing bills keep making your job
position relevant so that complexity
grows
not because i believe in it and i
believe what this this you know uh
nation could be
but a lot of it is self-preservation so
it builds this bureaucratic bureaucratic
complexity that just can't
sustain for very long a lot of people
are commenting saying i'm wrong states
don't have the authority to deport
people only the federal government does
but i kind of uh uh
i don't i don't know how that makes
sense i mean i i i accept that i may be
wrong on that i just mean like the
states have to have the ability to be
like you just illegally entered turn
around and go away you know what i mean
a federal crime though
i mean i guess but biden doesn't seem to
care about it so
if you're i mean look carrie lakes talk
at the very least i'll put it this way
fine maybe they can't legally
but couldn't they just
anyway i don't know i don't understand
well they're they're getting steamrolled
by the federal government on every
single level i mean even before
migrants are entering texas they are
getting cash-based interventions from
the un whose number one funder is the
united states and their government right
so american tax dollars are going to
funding migrants trip from south america
and mexico up to texas illegals trips
they're handing out these cards in
reynosa at migrant camps debit cards
from the u.n so that they can make it
there you can look this up on the center
for immigration studies it's a real
thing your tax dollars are directly
going to funding illegal migrants
journey up into texas okay hold on hold
on you know ian you talk about the fall
of rome a lot right and it seems like
what happened with rome was that
migrants started coming in
what if our adversaries studying that
said here's a way to destroy a country
started funding
mass migration but the us is funding it
the us are the number one you know
funder to
organizations like the un who are giving
the money the migrants so why are the
u.s destroying themselves i don't
understand that's a great question and
and like is the u.s a singular thing
anymore or is it or is it an organism
attacking itself why is tim smiling like
that
because i'm i'm seeing all the comments
people are making about bucko
and it's just hilarious sorry
he was getting this like ominous smile
like he knew something i'm petting the
cat while smiling like
freaking me out
and she's going down the street people
are posting like emojis and stuff in in
the chat and making jokes about bucko
she's very pleased yeah so bucko doesn't
seem to care enforcement officers cannot
arrest someone solely for illegal
presence for the purpose of deporting
them because it is a civil violation
didn't they have a something in place
where during covid they could like turn
them right around though
yeah so there was title 42. yeah but
they got biden got rid of that i don't
think yet i think court blocked him he's
trying to
we should hire mercenaries on the state
level to remove base
here's what i'll say though you know to
people who are saying that we can't
deport them okay well i'll say this
wouldn't they be better off being
detained or or something or uh
in some way
organized in such that we can
try and reduce crimes try and stop
criminals try and vet them in the
natural process like what i mean is if
we catch a bunch of illegal immigrants
our duty is supposed to be like okay
like let's figure out who you are what
you're doing here and go through that
process
why just send them to dc
the button administration has been
smuggling children trafficking kids on
military aircraft around the country
it just feels like you're paying half
the bill for them because they're that's
what they're trying to do
now they're going to call the national
guard and it's going to take more
taxpayer dollars their attitude is
probably like oh we don't care about
that like you're sending migrants to us
okay
we we we think them calling an emergency
is something bad for them but they're
probably just like cost of doing
business
um
was it okay wait i'm like looking this
up to make sure the story is real but i
heard that
israel was doing like re-migration where
they were paying people to go back to
their home countries for a while
i heard that denmark is doing that
because they actually do want to
encourage people to go back to wherever
they came from denmark is
doesn't really want a lot of immigration
to their country i guess they've really
been overwhelmed but it's denmark saw
what was going on with sweden with those
grenade attacks
denmark knows what's up yeah it's crazy
so when i was covering the sweden stuff
we were staying in copenhagen for a
little bit
and when you're going into sweden they
stop you and they check your ids
because they're worried about
the people who are coming out of sweden
there was the a few months before i had
gone there someone threw a grenade onto
a balcony killing an eight-year-old
english tourist oh i heard that yeah
grenading was a huge problem i don't
know if it still is but it was a huge
problem several years ago it still is
my wife is dutch and she's i mean he's
been seeing it for years her and her
family is that the the immigration waves
um it's really like
the cohesiveness that you would have had
in these neighborhoods before
starts to come apart the story you know
that that binds them all together starts
to come apart and um it's interesting
because also holland uh and and several
other places out there is where the
thing with the farmers
is
shooting at them right you know we're
about to run out of food so the best
thing is to uh stop farmers from doing
their job it's almost like it's on
purpose zubi called it a controlled
demolition yeah that's what i mean if
you listen to catherine austin fitz and
i know i mentioned her on this um show
before
she worked under george w bush um in the
um
in the 90s i think doing hud or
something like that but she said she
started getting some of her peers
telling her that the united states is
over we're moving assets to offshore
accounts um and we need a bunch of
forward-facing like public-facing events
that
will have the public not looking at what
the real perpetrator was
so she was she's been saying this for
years and she's probably one of the most
coherent speakers on the topic as you
can get and she was even saying with the
blm riots i think i might have mentioned
this before it was like 34 out of 37
of the riots happened within
like a just a very small perimeter
around the central banks there and her
theory was
you know it just makes it convenient
that like all this territory can be
built up as the smart grid which is what
the whole push is so build it up as the
smart grid
buy up this you know what do you mean
paw shops the infrastructure destroying
the businesses and creating crime which
drops property values so they can be
bought up and turned into a smart grid
that's what she says like i wouldn't go
so far as to say that you know but i
mean i wouldn't deny that that might be
an angle but this is catherine austin
fitz you know having worked under george
w bush uh i'm sorry herbert walker bush
in the 90s saying that she's been
tracking like where did that well over
21 trillion dollars of the the federal
budget go you know she's the one that's
been tracking all that so she was the
assistant secretary of housing and urban
development for housing under george w
bush
i saw a joke on reddit some guy was
saying when my rent prices start going
up i'll just go out into the
neighborhood and fire a couple shots off
to lower the housing prices
where it's like uh some guys like i
remember the department heard a gunshot
ran outside and the guy in the next door
said not to worry about it it was him
they just tried to keep the property
about the rent prices low yeah yeah yeah
oh well so i just want to confirm
because i i don't want to put fake news
on the tim cast right israel did have a
policy where they were um
giving financial aid to african
countries to send back african refugees
and migrants
they weren't even sending them back to
their home countries they were like
screw it just a place in africa rwanda
retreat will work we'll give you aid so
like if israel can do it why can't we
just
give you a bit of support we're sending
them all back
send them all to puerto rico i wonder if
it doesn't matter
i wonder if it can be solved because as
strict as trump was we still saw a
massive influx of migrants the caravans
all that stuff
you know trump trump was very serious
build the wall deport him you got to go
home you can come in legally all that
stuff and during his presidency we had
videos of people charging border guards
like migrant caravan running full speed
and attacking u.s borders it's happening
every day when i was i was just down
there in december and what's going on is
like you drive on the highway from
tapachula up to northern mexico you're
gonna run into a caravan every 20
minutes i'm not even joking but what's
going on is they'll block the highway to
try to get buses north and they'll
pressure the government oh these are
major shipping routes if you don't give
us a bus you're not you're basically
your country's not going to be able to
function so they'll get them buses but
what will happen
is then those buses will start to
transfer to come and get the caravan and
another caravan will block those buses
on the way up and then they'll have to
negotiate with those guys and it's just
absolute chaos there so when i make
jokes about oh we need to just start
deporting people and do this
we honestly do need some sort of policy
that is a yes or no open or closed
because it's actually destroying every
country in between it's destroying
mexico it's destroying the lives of
these people who have no idea what the
actual immigration system is in america
is there an immigration system i'm
seeing my cousin my nephew everyone get
in by walking in and when i apply
legally i can't get in so i guess that's
just how the u.s works i'm going to do
that everyone's life migrant refugee
mexican american is getting destroyed by
no clarity on this issue
it's really really harsh reality because
if you just say don't come in
and then they do it anyway
what do you do you arrest them and then
you deport them and then say please
don't come back and then they come back
and you're like what do you do like at a
certain point we're being attacked i
know right so the the cost of either
integration or repatriation is extensive
for us
we have to pay for planes we have to pay
for buses we have to pay for border
guards for police for first places where
these people can stay we have to pay for
medical treatment for their children and
they just keep coming i'm like we got a
serious problem that's not being dealt
with i mean look we got this story right
here
from nbc news biden administration to
fill uh border wall gaps near yuma
arizona
let me just uh break this story down for
you in a simple tweet from defiant else
karine jean-pierre tweeted in 2019
where are the pesos for your bigoted
wall to reel donald trump today she says
that they're filling major gaps in the
border wall because biden is trying to
save lives oh
these people have no logic there's no
morals it is just whatever their tribe
wants meaningless but i'm curious your
thoughts on this like why would the bite
administration be doing anything in
filling gaps in the border wall if
they're failing us to this degree i'm
well i have no idea is it like their
quota is done like okay that's all we
needed close the walls you know well i
mean it's
the truth is that the issue of illegal
immigration has been a football that's
been passed back between republicans and
democrats for years and nothing really
changes when it goes back and forth it's
always been a disaster it's always been
a massive problem honestly something
that's not really recognized is the
southern border program that obama
brought in place in 2014 was actually
massively successful he reduced illegal
migration from southern america by 70
percent
by putting mass funding into checkpoints
walls patrols down on the guatemalan
border so there are actually if you look
back and forth between republicans and
democrats their policies aren't that
different the whole thing is just a
disaster that they're all terrified to
address in a strong confident way
because no one wants to be seen as the
president that stopped all of the poor
refugees or children from coming in
whatever the policy will be publicly but
they know they can't just have
millions of people with no jobs no
background checks nothing sitting in
texas i figured it out remember that
story we were talking about the other
day where mexican citizens were getting
angry that americans were coming down
and they weren't speaking spanish
biden's building the wall to stop
americans from escaping
he's like no they're trying to get out
quick
gotta bring him in
gotta bring them in oh man yeah
the interesting thing is why even if
they want immigration for like supposed
economic reasons why all from central
and south america
like there's tons of immigrants from
european countries that would love to
come here i mean there's tons of
ukrainians that would love to come here
so i have
my friends who are in europe
talk about how difficult it is to get a
visa to fly to the u.s and they they say
you know everyone knows you fly to
mexico you can walk in and you're fine
but when you try to do it legally they
make it diff like impossible my wife is
still going through immigration and it's
been since 2017.
and she said she's from the netherlands
yeah i mean that's the eu it should be
easy yeah right you walk around she
speaks perfect english and she's married
to u.s citizen right and we have three
kids wow the cartel offer like
full-blown deals for people that are
typically from asia um
era arab countries uh a lot of places
you can pay like 50 grand to get traffic
through mexico into the us
as someone that has money that just
doesn't want to wait for the official
system i was meeting nigerians in
reynosa that were like actually i'm just
walking up to canada this is just easier
than applying for a visa i'm visiting a
friend in nova scotia is what one guy
told me
and he figured he'd take the route
through mexico and through the us
instead of just waiting on a visa
because it was easier
it's just crazy didn't you
were you were looking at americans who
were fleeing into canada
americans fleeing into canada yeah
didn't you go up and track that story
something like oh haitians that that was
a while back yeah there were haitians
walking through
roxum road up into uh quebec i believe
um that felt they were going to get
deported by trump after their refugee
status had
gone up and they were going to get sent
back to haiti we opened our whole
stadium there for them and it was wild
because
you could literally just take a taxi to
this suburban neighborhood walk across
this pathway and the canadian police
were sitting there and they'd pick up
your luggage for you and just walk you
down to the stadium and give you a bed
there's no we have no borders it's all a
joke and i i don't blame any migrant for
coming in illegally when this is what
they watch on the news it's like okay i
guess this is how your system works your
cops are literally waiting there for us
with buses and we'll take our luggage
for us and this happens in texas too
they've got buses ready to transport
them they're like come on in whatever
what would they have done in 1960 if
this was happening
we had very different immigration in
1960 like it wasn't
you know we didn't have the mass welfare
state
states that we do now right if you came
in it was like you're working or you're
dying so we didn't have so many people
that didn't have jobs and didn't have
support systems migrating it was people
that were ready to come in and die or
work
right
but now they're getting unemployment or
like now that we've got massive support
systems the immigration is very
different okay what if
we built huge treadmills
or you know yeah no better yet
platforms
that when you when you step on them it
spins a gear which generates power so
when all of these people are illegally
crossing the border they're all
trampling these things pushing these
boxes down generating electricity
and
powering our grid sounds like slavery
with extra steps bud
i don't know what we do but
you know
and then if they're planting like
pollinator flowers to bring the bees
back no no like what we do is
as they cross the border they get
blasted with pollen so they're running
through this field pressing buttons with
pollen you know just
pouring off their bodies
and then
once they get in
we take them and immediately put them in
a pneumatic tube which sends them back
to their country i can't wait for the
media matters article on this idea back
to the tube yes tim makes rick and morty
reference
they're outraged by it no my point is
rather sarcastic as to what the us
government is actually doing
the they're creating second-class
citizens they're talking about giving
ideas to these people so they can have
benefits okay so they can't vote they'll
struggle to find work
but they'll let them be here to work
yeah they're creating serfs the the
democratic party and their republican
neocon cohorts
they're creating a surf class yeah i'm
not for that
i'm not i'm not for that i think people
should enter legally they should be
treated respectfully i don't think
non-citizens should vote but if you're a
legal resident with the right to work
then congratulations we can hang out we
can crack beers and then pastor citizen
citizenship test understand what this
country means and why it means what it
means
come and vote man we're excited to have
you but just letting anybody come in at
any time
nah man and when your goal is to reduce
racism in society or whatever which is
what many progressives claim their goal
is do you really think that's going to
happen when the only if you're living in
a poor you know white neighborhood
growing up and then a bunch of people
come in and the only thing they do is
they can't speak the same language as
you they only work lowest class minimum
wage jobs that like you're creating this
perception in society of us and them
when you don't have any sort of
assimilation that takes place and
there's no differences in groups of
people that come in it's all just one
very
low working class
you know non-integrated group of people
that's like a recipe for disaster
they're creating and i don't i hope they
realize i think they realize what
they're doing if they do realize damn
that's dark
yeah the assimilation part is
interesting because like if you i mean
why do people say new york is so lonely
when there's so many people it's it's i
mean like
i wouldn't go so far as to say that's
absolutely true but when you have people
in the same neighborhood that for one
maybe can't speak the same language but
they don't belong to the same culture
that right there creates separation in
the very same neighborhood
you know there's there's something about
like
that that kind of rips the story apart
that kind of holds together like why is
this going to be a good neighborhood at
all you got to be a part of the same
story and that doesn't seem like that's
a care for any of any of the immigrants
it's it doesn't seem like you know come
in and as you were saying understand
what this you know nation is
uh or or what bonds us together
regardless of the nation like what bonds
us together and that's what my wife was
saying about holland it was just this
influx of immigration and there was this
rift not just language-wise but like a
lot of the immigrants as she was saying
and she saw it just did not care about
the culture or the glue that that
connected the people the swedish prime
minister has come out just um a few
months ago and said we are living in two
parallel societies and this is a
left-wing swedish prime minister not
right-wing anyways and and she's like
yeah it's becoming a crisis in our
country these people are not
assimilating they're not getting jobs
they're not speaking the same language
we've got two countries they're 30 years
too late yep yeah so uh i went down to
sweden and i was hearing all this
rhetoric from people on the right saying
that
the the refugees were creating all this
crime
i went there and found not true actually
completely not true i mean a little bit
but not really like the narrative of
migrant refugees burning cars and stuff
some of those things were happening the
reality was the children
swedish citizens
descendants of somali migrants from the
90s
were
uh are the cause of a lot are there are
the ones perpetrating a lot of the crime
the reason was
when the somali refugees and migrants
came to sweden in the 90s they said just
put them all in one place and forget
about them
so these people had no incentive to
learn the language and no ability to get
jobs because swedes are extremely racist
it is it is it is like everything you
think about wokes you know wokism sweden
they claim to be for diversity but
they're extremely racist so the these
are the kind of people that will be like
oh yeah you know racism is so wrong and
it's like here's a migrant
don't bring that person near me so what
they did was they put all the somali
migrants in places like rinkaby is one
place i think it was
where a lot of somali people end up
living they have kids those kids are
raised by people of somali descent
they're treated by swedish by other
people in sweden by native swedes as
immigrants even though they were born
there speak the language and are
citizens they go home to visit their
their families on their parents side in
somalia and they're called swedish
they're not called so they have no
country so what happens when the police
come into their neighborhoods they say
you are not a part of our society at all
you are just people in a van as far as
we are concerned you can't do anything
here so we actually had this was like
one of the most contentious moments when
we had cops tell us they start throwing
stones at us what can we do
we just leave that happened to us in
paris years and years ago do you
remember when we were in that no-go zone
in paris and the cops told us like if
something happens you're on your own
which one was this was that was are you
sure you were there i'm pretty sure you
were there oh wait wait wait wait there
were riots going on yeah remember we
left you in the falafel store to die
i remember though there's like a big
there were big protests and we couldn't
get back to the to the airbnb or
whatever or something like that yeah
they started yelling at us that they
were going to kill us and our translator
said that and we were like where's tim
when we were going to find our car and
you were in the falafel store like
that's all i i'm like that was me
absolutely sure i did a video on it
really shout out to falafel and you were
like forget tim we need to go
for real
maybe i need to watch the video to
remember
years ago
yeah i do remember in france like there
were big protests and the trains were
blocked off and the cops wouldn't let
anyone through and stuff like that we
went to a few yeah
yeah yeah yeah northern parts of france
i think i remember this there was like a
lot of crime there were shootings
and and locals were like scared
i remember when i went to sweden the
first time this guy was scared to drive
in certain neighborhoods
because he was just like these
neighborhoods have become like their own
you know they colloquially call them
no-go zones and then the media was like
there's no such thing as a no-go zone
you look at the definition and it's like
a no-go zone is an area where you know
there's like high crime where police
tell you to avoid
and like you either can't go there
you're told to avoid going there and so
in these areas like you actually had
swedish police issue statements saying
like these are high crime areas but then
deny that they were in any way no go
zone and i'm like my attitude was
i don't care what they're officially the
locals just refer to them that way and
the cops too the cops will say it too
they're like this is a no-go zone just
so you know oh but those don't exist by
the way yeah just don't say that does it
compare to a favela
i think favelas are awesome because i i
mean at least when i was in brazil
favelas were just like
shantytowns you know in brazil
regular people live in regular lives
they're just you know poorer
and so the crazy thing was how people
built houses on top of and through other
people's houses
so like we went to one house where they
have a neighbor the neighbor one day
just climbed up on top of the roofs and
started building another house to get to
it they have to go through the house
nobody cares i was like wow that's kind
of crazy i haven't seen that but i've
been to some favelas that i would never
go back to what is a favela it means
this is shantytown yeah like in brazil
it's it's supposed to be like a
dangerous area is that the other yeah
and it's it's definitely the lowest
economic areas and sometimes they're
right next to like a high economic area
those are the most dangerous one there's
like a contrast if you go to super poor
areas in the world where there's no
contrast there's no like jealousy or
like trying to strive for that wealth or
whatever people are perfectly content
it's when there's that like developing
societies are really rough i don't know
man i mean maybe they're dangerous
but maybe because i'm from chicago i
just didn't feel that way to me no i
mean that literally could be because you
know they say chicago's my chicago's got
more gun deaths than iraq going to bed
at night in the city and then hearing
gunshots in the distance is just
something you grew up with have like
someone pulling out a gun
at my local high school fight breaks out
and somebody pulls out a gun it's just
like i'm in i'm in the favelas in brazil
and it's like a dude with like an open
fire just grilling chicken and we're
like is it cool they're like playing
music and people were just chilling and
i was like i don't know have you seen
city of god no it's it's all about the
favelas really really good story but
it's about how like the the the children
gangs gangs that were literally like
kids from maybe four or five years old
all the way up to like 15 with guns were
like running some of these favelas you
know what you got to understand though
is that uh
most people aren't insane you know what
i mean like i don't know about that one
but no i mean
there are insane people but i typically
find in in my my travels having covered
you know conflict crisis uh being in
these like being in uh anarchist
districts in like turkey is that their
goal there's a goal there's an idea
there's like you can see what they're
doing and why they're doing it they're
not the joker so like when i'm in the
favelas they're like here's likely
what's gonna happen like if someone
wants to steal from you they're gonna
take your stuff
i was i was warned when i was in
venezuela they were like when you get
expressed kidnapped in venezuela they'll
give you a ride anywhere you want to go
like their goal is to take your money
not to destroy your life for the most
part so they one guy told me a story
where he was like he went to an atm
machine and as soon as he walked up guy
walked up to him and said you know take
your money out and then now get in the
car they're driving in the car and
they're like
there's a guy pointing a gun and he's
like give me your wallet give me your
stuff give me your phone give me all
your cash where can we drop you off and
he's like oh you can drop me off here
and like it was like a 20 minute drive
and then like drove him they're like man
have a go on he's like all right bye
that's nice of them well cause like
there are bad people some of these
people will kill you but if you look at
some of these videos out of brazil you
see them so often where someone's
robbing a store and they get shot and
killed
you may notice
like in these videos the dude robin is
not prepared to shoot anyone like have
you seen these videos i think i know the
idea you're talking about tons of them
yeah a guy will walk into a store and
then he'll pull out a gun and start
pointing and then everyone just unloads
on him the dude will try and run away
because they were threatening these
people but not really prepared to
actually do it but when you point a gun
at someone they're prepared to defend
their own lives this is the issue these
people they're doing these robberies
they're not actually prepared to hurt an
innocent person but these people with
the guns aren't innocent so those people
are my point is in my experience having
been to a lot of countries
if you just try and understand the
people and their motivations you're
typically fine that's a really good
point i think the people you have to be
the most scared of are it's the classic
thing the people who have nothing left
to lose like you never get in a fight
with a crackhead you're going to lose
every time or at least they're going to
gouge your eyes out
before or like you look at like the
situation where those two girls were
beheaded in morocco in the mountains by
these migrants who had been sitting
there for years trying to get over the
into suede maria milia over the fences
and they just
they can't go back don't have enough
money destroyed their passports can't go
forward
nothing left to lose let's chop these
girls heads off after assaulting them
like geez those are the scary but you're
right people have motivations that you
can identify
you might be fine right but that also
means like when you're seeing someone
when you see isis you're like i know
their motivations run yeah yeah yeah
like the average person so my point is
like you're going to a favela the
average motivation of a person is i'm
going to get food for my family i'm
going to get nice clothes and try and
just live so then when they come up to
and they threaten you it's like if you
just give them your stuff
they're going to leave you alone or
you can figure out you know are they
really prepared to fight with you and if
typically you see this in the united
states too they did this uh study
they got a bunch of [ __ ]
convicted criminals who had committed
armed robberies showed them videos of
people walking and asked them who would
they choose to target
turns out like over 80 of the time the
people they chose had been robbed before
there was something about the way people
carried themselves that made them look
weaker and susceptible so that's you can
understand these things for the most
part when i would go to like the favelas
you know that almost all people don't
want trouble
like
a fox for instance
will not come onto our property when the
dog's around unless the fox is starving
and it has no choice and that's the
issue so most people like when you when
you come across someone who's like
desperate
they might you know not want to destroy
you but they'll take your stuff the real
scary thing is ideologues because you
know they want to destroy you because
those people are crazy
depending on where you are like there
was that one uh story about the two
people riding their bikes through
tajikistan or whatever and then isis
just rammed rammed them and like ran
them over or whatever because like you
know
some places are are dominated by
ideologues and zealots you got to watch
out for that i tell you this
i would gladly with a smile on my face
walk through any favela in brazil
going to stores hanging out with people
and not worry about it
but i would be much much more worried to
go to like
a protest in new york city where there's
leftists you know what i mean cause i
know i know their motivations the
motivations on the left is violence
bricks anger and rage they'll scream in
your face they'll they'll do what they
did to andy know and if a vela it's
people they want to sell you a
cheeseburger man yeah cheeseburger might
you know have worms in it depending on
who you're getting cooked from but
no one there wants to be known on the
internet as the guy who threw a brick at
tim's pool's head like it doesn't they
don't care that the publisher yeah yeah
no there's whereas new york that's
probably a few that's really what's
really messed up though is the favela
tours they started doing a while ago
where rich tourists will get on buses
and drive through poor neighborhoods as
a tourist attraction
that's disgusting that is super nasty
geez i feel like i'm looking at images
of favelas thinking about how cool they
look they do i'm kind of like that that
guy on taking a tour right now but you
pull up the image he's just doing it on
the internet it's a spectacular
spectacular imagery to see the way they
build these houses in these communities
well i mean they're like doctors filled
with any
yeah there's probably no structural
integrity like there's no building codes
and whatever getting getting from
building the building is the craziest
thing because there's like zigzagging
narrow quarters like one human body
length wide
i went to uh uh uh what was it um
what is it called it it's uh
policia i think my portuguese doesn't
it's not existent they had it they they
had built a mock favela for trainings
for for favela policing and
combat because the favelas are random
you know like in in in the states it's a
grid system we use for most cities so
there's a logic there's a logic to it
but in favelas it's like you're going to
turn the corner and some guy's going to
pop out of a window that was really fun
when i went down there because we
climbed on top of their mock favela and
i think it was like eight feet or ten
feet and then i asked the cop and i was
like what do you do when you're up here
and the guy down guys down there and
he's like and then he jumps down he's
like just like that and then i jumped
down after him and he was like whoa he
was like don't get hurt man i'm like i'm
good and he was actually really
surprised i did it because you know he
thought like we do training here we can
handle it and i'm like i've been skating
yeah you skateboard i was like i can
jump off a building i'm good i bet
they're pretty good at parkour oh yeah
no for real man that's that's why the
police needed to build this place
build a mock favela for training because
you're trying to chase down a dude who
lives there home field advantage yeah
no but seriously it's a maze
i'm telling you i went to one house to
get to the neighbor's house you had to
walk through their kitchen like walk
through their house to get to the next
house this is like perfect assassin's
creed territory yeah there's jump
everywhere all over the but they well
the crazy thing is the power lines
because yeah yeah
but they've been they've been doing for
a while now something called uh
reclamation or pacification where
they've been sending in these like
high-powered
tactical units rifles to just clear out
the gangs
the gangs
were the real government of the favelas
yeah because there was no government so
what happens is the gangs they'd call
them
started to like locals would organize
and come up with their own systems of
governance that's what humans do
when the government tried to say like
hey these people should be paying taxes
and we should have control of this
they went in and started rounding these
people up shooting them in many
circumstances it was pretty brutal just
another gang
yep you know there's a pretty euphoric
way to get mugged and uh i think it's
like ecuador and columbia they use toei
or scopolamine where you just like
it's this powder that you can put on a
piece of paper and they'll go up to like
tourists and they just blow it in their
face and then makes you so suggestible
that you're like all right can you can
you go to the atm can you pull out all
the cash that you have and not take me
back to your uh hotel or wherever you
stay in where where are your valuables
and you'll just say it you'll give it up
and people are shocked they like don't
remember yeah they blow it in your face
it's the zombie drug yeah it's i think
it's the strongest nightshade scopola
means scopolamina comes i
don't think it comes that's a really
respectable respectable way to mug
someone right that's very i'd like to
get mugged that way someday yeah
chemically if i'm going to get mugged
that's going to be the one no i'll i'll
do it regardless
they call it the devil's breath the
scopolamine yeah some put it in
ayahuasca as well they call it toei but
they make it an administer a mixture of
uh ayahuasca and then sometimes people
get taken advantage of that way but i
kind of feel like
it's gotta be
uh
an urban legend the potency of
scopolamine
you know maybe like these stories of
people
someone will like walk up to them at the
atm and then do like the witch doctor
thing where they go
and blow in your face and you're like
and then they zombify you that's crazy
like how does that actually happen you
know
i wonder the same thing about treats
motion sickness oh okay
yeah what is there what are we gonna say
well i was just like the i was just
reading this thing in this weird
magazine crime thought nachos crime
about me
about pcp and like leading it you know
to cannibalism pcp leading people into
cannibalism and how many stories
came up with that well when i was in
mexico something really interesting i
was told was that you know all the human
sacrifices they did in like what was it
mayan culture
the sorry the aztecs not like um they
were telling me that they'd put the
people on like shrooms and tons of
different drugs and they actually wanted
to be sacrificed because they thought it
was like such a noble important death
and when they were on all these drugs it
was actually like this beautiful
experience it made um people's hearts
being eaten a lot more lovely for me
romantic what if that's how you ascend
you take dmt until you blast off sending
your spirit into the fourth dimension
then they sacrifice your body
severing the tether and keeping you
trapped in the fourth dimension you're
on another level right now man i feel
like i'm on dmt so your spirit's already
in the other dimension you don't have to
experience the visceral transaction
you're already peacefully there and then
they kick you down a flight of steps and
your friends eat your heart that's cute
yeah if you guys thought it was
apocalypto yeah yeah yeah
did you guys watch vikings i haven't
seen it no wasn't that like a thing in
vikings too uh where they'd talk about
how it it was like a huge honor to be
sacrificed to the gods and people would
want to get that position
it was definitely i mean i don't know
how much vikings is like
referencing historical information but
i just know that's like a theme
the litho ancient lithuanian
cults and stuff would do that for sure
what are these pagan
they would even take body parts or eat
body parts of you know the conquered
peoples
well i guess that's
yeah this is still a thing today you
have like isis members that are like bam
i'm going to blow myself
reading reading the crime about
scopolamine they don't blow in your face
they just lace your drink with it so is
there a video of someone getting dosed
with scopolamine and then being like yes
master or anything like that no it just
it's a roofie like i'm reading about it
it just makes you like delirious and
loopy so you're probably like
wow
and then they're like what's your atm
number and you go man
i kind of feel like there's going to be
a youtuber that's like today i'm going
to get cannibals
well vice versa one of the very early
things was like they got some scopolami
and they were like whoa and they flush
down the toilet they don't touch it i
saw this one yeah there was a vice
anchor that would go out and do a bunch
of drugs is it hannibal is that his name
animal no it's uh hamilton hamilton
hamilton
hannibal hannibal's pharmacopoeia yeah
um hamilton's pharmaceuticals
hamilton's like for i'm gonna do this
for you and then he would take all these
different trunks and be like now you
know what it's like for me to be on
drugs but i mean he did a that's a lot
of great work he did wasn't his dad a
famous guy who was his dad
i can't remember but you're right yeah i
meant i met him and he really does talk
that slow
oh cool
would you ever eat someone like another
person okay but like what like who are
we
name someone and i'll tell you okay like
there were those people that got in that
plane crash
that had to eat
their friends stay alive would you do
that no doubt arrow morris okay so you
would like everyone said no but you're
lying to me you would be to be to be
perfectly legit if i had to to survive
the answer in that situation would
probably be yes no
no no never you know
no conditions you would eat another
person under nope you just let yourself
die
i just want to point out there are
people who starve for political purposes
intentionally like bro i'm pretty sure
it's a choice if you want to eat another
person but if there's no politics
involved if it's just well okay what
about are you talking about living
people or people that are already frozen
my point is there are people right now
who are like i feel so strongly about
the birds i'm not going to eat another
chicken until the birds are freed and
then they choose to starve themselves so
my point is how many people actually die
of that starvation though they're like
people who want hunger strikes yeah they
actually like go the whole way instead
of doing it for like three days and then
damn i'm gonna go get myself some like
expensive vegan food
maybe maybe it's easy to say when i'm
well fed but i don't do not believe
there's a circumstance where i would eat
a person you know how do you get the
breath there
it's not survival you get the shakes you
get prion disease don't eat the brain no
but it's you can't even guarantee it you
eat the people you get the shakes
what do you mean the shakes what is that
from from eating
encephalopathy or something yes i'm not
advocating eating other people here i'm
just you know right well
the new york times had that article
they're like the time for cannibalism
maybe now
they were they were writing soylent
green eh
yeah well they're they were writing
about fiction how like it's become
popular cannibalism and fiction my
response is like reza oslan ate people
like he ate a person he got in real big
trouble for that and they they
broadcasted what was it cnn yeah he ate
eight people
he i i got he ate part of a piece of a
brain yeah i don't know i meant people
in like the general noun like saying cow
you know he ate human
piece of a brain is an ecosystem so
would he get the he wouldn't get the
shakes when you talk about someone
getting the shakes i think i think reza
aslan may have had men may have a mental
side effect from eating brain i think it
like the dude is went went like off he's
like he was like this well-respected
religious scholar and then at some point
he just went nuts and he's like he
advocated for violence like with the
covington kids and stuff he he's posted
really insane stuff about punching like
he always said punch the kid's face
something like that the kid's face is
punchable i kind of feel like either
eating the brain
did something to him which i would not
be surprised
or
the social ramifications of being a
cannibal destroyed him mentally i get
that that's what i get out of it and
and i will always stress this because i
know somebody who knew him and i said
reza aslan is a cannibal and they were
like no he's not and i was like he's a
cannibal he ate human being and they
were like he ate a human like one time
and i'm like if a dude
abuses a kid you know what i mean like
are you gonna say he's not a pedo and
they're like well no i'm like he ate a
part of a person he's a cannibal
objectively again like you earned that
title dude great conversation so if
someone killed somebody 35 years ago
you're a murderer are they still a
killer yes or are they no longer a
killer now that they don't kill people
anymore you're a killer like i don't
think it's like once you did something
you're always that thing
so i i i sometimes eat the calluses off
my fingers i'm a guitar player all right
you're cannibals am i cannibal tell me
no you're not a cannibal dude you're
like like you you're constantly
swallowing mucus from the from like your
your sinus or whatever or you know or
like you know you bite your tongue and
then like some cells
wait okay so wait this actually brings
up an interesting conversation because
like i was thinking okay there has to be
the person has to be dead and then i was
like wait no they don't actually have to
be dead because you could like
unconsensually eat someone's i could
bite his arm right now and i think i'd
be a cannibal right but what if he
consented to me eating his mouth because
there's that guy in germany
but he got his guy that um he ate he had
him consent to it
and then he ate him and he went to jail
and they did a whole documentary on him
but the guy consented to being eating
eden was he under duress when he i don't
know he claims it's he claims that they
were lovers and that the guy loved him
so much he wanted to be a part of him
that was his claim when he did the
interview i think
i love where this conversation was
what is the guy's name
looking at that grand patron like i
think
is there is there a difference between
like consensual cannibalism and
cannibalism are you a worse person if
it's in 50 years there might be
different words for those two things
you know i i firmly believe
dogs know if you have ever eaten dog
hmm
because i was reading something about
about it how
dogs like i was reading about countries
where they eat dog and the behavior that
dogs have towards people and i'm like
if dogs can smell cancer if dogs can
smell a seizure before it happens
i'm pretty sure a dog can smell that
you've eaten dog at least recently
or maybe within the past few years or
something but like chickens don't have
the sense of smell is that why in cows
can they not smell as well as dogs have
crazies i think animals are closer to
the spirit realm especially dogs and
they can absolutely sense things on a
level that we can't and things about our
soul that's why dogs will like hate
certain people and cats too they can
anticipate your movements well i rather
see things we don't see i read that if
you eat dog dogs will like not trust you
horse you say wild horses too up in
northern california um
there was uh my friends got like a
thousand acres and there's wild horses
all around it and he's protecting them
and he said everybody he brings there if
you eat meat it doesn't even have to be
horse you know meat if you eat meat at
all the horses won't come near you
interesting
well i mean you can smell it they say
like when this when the special forces
or whatever we're training to go and or
i don't know what your division you have
to eat local foods because you don't
realize how much you smell of the food
that you eat interesting yeah so the
horses are probably like dude you eat
meat i can tell
and you're going to mcdonald's right
and then the vegans walk up and the
horse is like ah a noble vegan yeah i am
safe around you
as i am a vegan um okay i just just for
a reference for the checks i'm sure
there's so many people interested the
guy's name was armin miwis who is the
cannibal in germany who's victim
consented
how do they know he can send it though
um apparently
there's a whole documentary on it okay
there's like a kind of signed contract
yeah i think it was like they had like
letters back and forth and stuff and
they yeah they were
was he's like i want to be in you are
you sure you just didn't
misread that statement
okay wait
milos appeared in court charged with
killing and then frying and eating
another man in one of the most
extraordinary trials uh the
self-confessed cannibal admitted that he
had met 43 year old berlin engineer
bernard brandes after advertising on the
internet and had chopped him up and
eaten him so i think he put a
advertisement on the internet that he
wanted to eat someone and the guy
responded
what platform
crazy this is what the internet does to
people
like normally a guy who wants to be
eaten would never find someone who would
want to eat him but now there's someone
forever now you can swipe until you find
the right one there's going to be an app
called eater eatery and it's like i
would like to be eating or i would like
to eat in your life no i don't want to
eat him i'd eat her oh man eaters only
so he was nice about it brandon
swallowed 20 see sleeping tablets and a
half a bottle of schnapps before he
started oh i i don't think i do still
alive he started cutting off certain
parts of him first and started to fry
and eat it and then after he was
bleeding heavily he took a bath he read
him a star trek novel
and then in the early hours of the
morning he finished off his victim
stabbing him in the neck and then
kissing him yeah the way they call it
victim i mean if this already
predisposed like they already believed
it was uh not consensual chopped him up
put several bits of him in the freezer
next to a takeaway pizza then buried him
in the garden
next defrosted and because i love that
detail right there he read
he cut him up ate him while he was still
alive and then read him a star trek
novel i just yeah
but here's the problem like
this i mean i'm serious about the
internet stuff no normally somebody who
thought they were a giraffe would just
sit there and they're quiet being like i
think i'm a giraffe and then
they would never act upon it but now
with the internet they find a bunch of
other people who are like yo i think i'm
a giraffe too and they're like let's
have a giraffe convention then they all
get together walking around going man
eating leaves
and it's it's like
it's creating communities that normally
wouldn't exist you know i need more i
think humans used to be way more
racist and and willing to slo slaughter
that which they hated and we become very
like accepting for better and for worse
because yeah we become much more
tolerant which obviously is fantastic
for for a communicative society but at
the same time
how would those people survive in nature
if like they just want to be giraffes
all day
like how who's going to do the human
work
see i wonder like who would they be
in a in a tribe like you go back
thousands of years
like who who would they be that tribe
right the one who thinks they're a
giraffe like you know or are they the
shaman
could they even do they even think that
stuff back in the day do you think it's
just like a lazy like there's nothing
i'm bored with there's no so let's find
out let's fantasize
it's like the kids who are like when we
achieve full communism i'm gonna work at
the poetry factory
you saw that meme where they're like
what are you gonna do when communism is
achieved it's like i'm gonna teach
people how to grow things on my farm and
then someone went your farm yeah
yeah they don't they don't get it you
mentioned earlier that the people we
seem to have had a story like a group
story that we're out of touch with now
but what do you think that story is
i mean like i love charles eisenstein's
way of looking at this and he says like
you know there's this old story that
it's it's not like you know some some
emperor or some group writes it per se
it kind of is an amalgamation of a group
you know an entire group but over time
it kind of turns into
an unwritten credo and like part of it
today i would say is that like we're
we're separate from nature
um that you know you can do anything you
want to the environment and it it
doesn't you know come back on you
uh that like you know money can be
profane and completely separate there's
nothing sacred about you know any of
these things so like in a sense it's
kind of this isolationist i'm this
individual and the way charles
eisenstein is talking about it is like
this is this is precisely what we need
to get back to is more of the the real
story that unites us being this thing
where there's nothing i can do to the
outside world that doesn't eventually
have its consequence back at me or in
future generations so i think those are
the kinds of stories it's not like you
know
something that you can write down in a
preamble to a constitution or something
like that i think it's it's more of like
the amalgamation of what people end up
believing
under a certain kind of rule under a
certain kind of economy we talked about
the eight types of greek love a couple
nights ago you brought it up and the
agape you actually mentioned is the love
of the community and i think people have
fallen maybe in the united states out of
touch with it because of this
isolationist ease of like air condition
you know internal but i i i know you get
to be separate you get to you get to
look at everything through a screen now
whereas back in the day like you would
gauge your threat level by looking into
nature
and now everyone is is getting the same
amygdala teasing effect by just staring
at a screen
and but you're safe inside this
supposedly safe inside this little
bubble but you're cut off from your
actual community
we've got to figure something out us
humans because uh
you know we developed and evolved based
on the natural ecosystem like the
simplest thing is sugars are few and far
between in nature so when we find it
we're like this is amazing because your
body uses it really quickly and then you
don't have it for a long time then we
refined it now we have endless supplies
of sugar pumped into our bodies
poisoning us
these things are are one of the biggest
threats to
like everything that is to be human you
know we want to we want to better our
lives we want to make a better future
for our children we want to explore
develop become smarter and live and be
happy and healthy but now
it's like we've found a way to
electrocute our nerve to stimulate it
and we just got the thing cranked up to
11 and we're sitting there with
movies video games porn mountain dew
taco bell chocolate ice cream ben and
jerry's whatever you want to call it and
it's just massive over stimulation
and i think it desensitizes people
because i'll tell you this one of the
most we've got the black like the berry
season's almost over
but i talk about wine berries all the
time it is like
they're so delicious when i don't eat i
don't eat sugar for the most part so
when you get a fresh berry you're like
whoa it's so good
and then it's like i tried drinking uh
sweet tea and i was it was like drinking
syrup i couldn't drink it it was
disgusting i think people are completely
desensitized to like the amount of
garbage they're eating they're probably
they're not getting the same like this
is why people are so depressed too
once you get everything that can
maximize stimulation there's nothing
left
so if your whole life is pure
stimulation
you're at the top you can't go anywhere
eventually just becomes baseline you're
like life is not good some i had
breathing issues i don't know if it was
like a panic attack or something but i
had to go to the hospital once for it
because i was like having so much
trouble getting air and i remember the
doctor talking i felt like such a loser
because he was like there's nothing
actually wrong with you just how you're
breathing right now is your
lungs are full and you're only going
you can't get anything in so you're
never feeling like you're getting a full
breath and that sounds like exactly what
you're describing like if you start at
the bottom you're always getting these
full breaths every single day
and yeah you just don't want to
constantly be hitting that peak how do
people work out of that i it was like i
don't know if i feel like such a loser
because i thought there was something
like severely wrong with me but yeah it
was like an anxiety thing or something
and i just had to chill for a bit
i've told this story before a friend of
mine who uh became a millionaire at age
of 16 i think he was like 16. said that
in his experience every person he's ever
met who became wealthy had an
existential crisis
for most of these people
they
weren't intending to become rich
they developed something instantly
became rich and then had accomplished
their goal and did not have to work
anymore and so that left them sitting
there depressed and aimless
because like
if their goal was i'm gonna you know
work on this computer program and they
just kept improving it over time
they'd have to keep working and paying
their bills and then finding ways to
make money but for the small amount of
people who
solved the computer problem instantly
made 10 15 million dollars now they
don't got to work they're like what is
my life now
i've already accomplished the thing that
i'm good at i have money i don't have to
work anymore what do i spend it on
everyone else is too busy working they
can't i'm just you're outside of the
system at that point there's an
interesting thing there's like two
spiritual elements to this that i want
to bring up is that one
i bet you those people would be happier
if they like woke up to this wealth and
then they realized everybody else is
free as well but when you wake up and
all of a sudden you're outside of this
rat race where you have to you have to
like you know work your ass off in this
dog eat dog world
so you wake up and you're outside of
that you don't have to work anymore but
every one of your friends you can't
solve all their problems for them so
you're watching them
stuck in this machine that you were just
in and it might feel lonely outside of
that and that's actually what they call
the bodhisattva in
buddhism and
are people who reach nirvana which is
like enlightenment pure bliss but
they're like
like i realize i don't exist for me so
they enter themselves back into the
world of suffering so they can help
other people and what you were saying
like breath is a part of every single
spiritual tradition
and when you're at the top of your
breath all the time it leads to anxiety
you know but what does this look like
it's like you know the bottom of your
breath all the time people who they're
not inhaling and getting that full
inhale is more like depression
everything's lived in the tension yeah
yeah conflict is a huge part of life
that makes life enjoyable
and it's unfortunate that sometimes that
conflict is war
but you know going back to like the
first thing we're talking about the
decline of an empire is that when the
the narrative of god and country wasn't
working anymore your country's falling
apart people
a country succeeded because people were
like we are a strong country we believe
in each other and that that bond
you lose that
there's you know people just conflict
with each other everything falls apart
but uh let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
don't forget check out timcast.com we've
got a couple shows up now uh the entails
from the inverted world we're about to
so we have tales from the inverted world
which is the you know serialized long
form show and we're going to be
launching soon the inverted world
podcast which is shane cashman the
author taking your calls
so we want we're going to be setting
this up soon we'll have you submit your
ghost stories your spooky stories your
paranormal your bigfoot sightings and
then shane will ask you guys about them
so we'll schedule calls with regular
people have them phone in we'll do these
episodes
i'll try we'll try and do him as often
as shane is able to do him it might be
once a week it's going to be up to him
because he's also going to be
investigating some other long-form stuff
for tales from the united world
but i'm really excited for that show
because i just personally
love those shows like i don't know if
you guys have ever won a road trip and
just put on the the campfire ghost
stories shows those are my favorites
yeah are you uh what was that old afraid
of it not afraid of the scary stories to
tell in the dark yeah i was raised on
that book and i audio like the tape that
came out with it i love being on a road
trip
it's like 10 p.m it's dark and playing
on the podcast is like a dude calling in
being like so there was i'm in my
basement when all of a sudden the water
faucet turns on by itself and i'm like
whoa
you can hear he believes it too i don't
know what's wrong with you people i
can't do anything horror my nightmares
are enough for me thanks i'm kind of
with you i'm good on that
life is terrible paranormal
no like i have such bad i want
i have such bad nightmares like i can't
do any of that i get sleep paralysis i'm
like no no no that's just going to give
my mind more creativity to torment me
with my brother so we went to an antique
store and we got a phone from the 1930s
like one of those old like you pull the
cone off the thing and put it to an
operator and uh my brother turned it in
he actually built a mechanism to make it
work with like
actual bluetooth and play sounds and
everything so we're going to use that as
like a main prop and then we have a we
actually have a haunted house that we're
going to be using for the set so i'm
super excited but let's re let's read
all your super chats
all right let's see kefka says so i see
people want to bring back the ghost girl
i also see it's either uh it's either
ian is always on or it'll be another
summer of love i for one agree i don't
understand what that means um
mary morgan is the host of pop culture
crisis and she does frequent this show
uh so you'll see her
periodically
all right let's see s says cheez-it if
lauren is sucking down pappy in a paper
cup i'm bringing mezcal in a mason jar
that's right
oh so did you put the honey in the in
the grand patron i did how was it is it
good
it's really strong but yeah it's all
right i i can make you one right now
make me one i'm gonna go i i do think
would you would you guys not me okay uh
i might yeah tiny tiny paper cups boys
every day
for the environment all right let's grab
some more
oh no i can't read some of these
eraftis of stats says how do i audition
for the part of tim in the cast castle
series
um you you don't i don't know
so we we are going to have in the cast
castle show
real vlog elements of it
like lauren was riding on an electric
motorbike or something like that it was
we should have i still think we should
have logged whatever this thing the nad
thing oh the name yeah um i we never
really do that i guess for like security
reasons we never film it fair enough um
wait i'm curious who would you have play
you like what actor would you have play
you in a movie about you i don't know
you have no idea
[Laughter]
i have no idea i don't know i i imagine
like there's you know they're gonna make
they're gonna make a movie you know how
they did the fox news bombshell movie
yeah they're gonna make an indie media
one mostly about the daily wire but i'll
be like peripherally in it for some
reason and then they'll get like some
really awful person to play me some like
weasley guys like i'm tim ho hang come
on yeah
jessie pinkman from breaking bad
whatever that actor's name is
he's in westworld now
i don't know maybe they have to get ben
shapiro to play me because
all he would have to do is be a little
bit more liberal but we both talk really
fast so i think he'd be able to pull it
off
people liked fast talkers hey in media
everyone's just got a bit of adhd i
can't even watch my my videos not on two
times speed anymore i have to watch
everything on two times speed uh
internet you make it your own
do you edit your own videos most of them
yeah yeah do you edit on
double time
if i could i would that's what i do for
my shows
and i notice when i watch them at
regular speed i'm like whoa this sounds
like i'm drunk yeah
all right
let's read some more doc toxic says
finally joined timcast.com and watched
the after show hearing ian drop the
f-bomb for the first time made it so
worth it yes
huron x bearcat says everyone gives ian
too much crap i don't necessarily agree
with him a lot of the time but ian
brings to light more dialogue in the
entire comment section keep it up ian
you silly goose no thanks dog the things
the the things we don't like semantic
arguments yeah the things we do like ian
has a perspective that is very much
outside of the typical culture war and
often you know presents things that no
one on the left or right is actually
addressing in a certain issue
i like talking about semantics if we
agree beforehand let's discuss a word
what it means what it used to mean what
it could mean that kind of stuff but
using it in the middle of a discussion
is kind of uh underhanded yeah when it
feels circular
thank you
all right very strong just look out hank
hokage hill says why don't you use
rumble you promote it a lot it would get
a lot of people to sign up and overall
get more people off youtube love you
guys
we use we use rumble for we put we put
everything on rumble that we put
everywhere else um i don't think the
full vod version of this goes on rumble
though unless we're we have to move it
over and the issue is i've explained it
a bit it's simple before i mention it
i'll also read story man jack who says
tim is a coward calls for us to quit our
jobs in protest but jumps like an
apoplectic toad when youtube grunts
hypocrisy much no
no um
my point is as it's always been for one
you're i respect your opinion if you
think that's the case um i will stand by
saying
youtube is the biggest platform i do not
think it makes sense for large and
prominent personalities to retreat from
the central battlefield of ideas
for some principled reason i agree with
principled reasons if it's like
you work for a company and they're doing
something really bad and you're like i
don't want to do that thing for you
on youtube we're doing the opposite of
bad thing we are calling out bad thing
we're calling out the problems and we're
using the most powerful and prominent
platform to
one address those issues and then also
create a pathway to alternates we shout
out the daily wire frequently because i
think what they're doing is equally as
important creating alternate paths we
shout out parallel economy we use them
we use rumble infrastructure my point is
when i say don't cancel your disney or
netflix if you really want to go ahead i
don't expect people to abandon the
establishment machine where it provides
for them in certain ways we have to
create a machine that does better so
simply put
when when jordan peterson got suspended
on twitter i said i think he should
delete the tweet and then go after
twitter on their own platform and use it
to the best of his abilities i don't
think you accomplish much by
you know it it would be like being in a
battlefield taking some casualties and
then being like all right that's it
we've got everybody retreat there's no
point in being here or do you pull a mel
gibson grab the flag and go no no no
keep going keep going keep going
it's not perfect there's no simple
solutions if you can work at a company
that's doing bad things but you are
completely able to push back and reverse
that then you shouldn't quit you you're
having a positive impact
so this is this this is what i think is
important maximizing central battlefield
to the best of our abilities so that
youtube continually promotes these
conversations to regular people
and then we can create paths to a whole
bunch of personalities to put it even
more simply
you may not like that we use youtube but
how else do we get the likes of alex
jones and steve bannon in front of
regular people when they've been banned
we still have an ability for regular
people to see things who was that that
made that super chat what was his name
or her name uh story man jax shout out
story man apopleptic toad is that the
word you the metaphor i like it that's
very good it's very good um but i will
also say i will read your comments if
you think i'm wrong because
like i think that's what actually makes
the show good so feel free to throw
shade my way and i'll give you my
thoughts on it and uh
far from perfect battlefield it's a cool
conversation because sometimes you do
want to retreat from a battle even one
maybe that you're winning because you
can pull the enemy into an ambush
sometimes when you start to take fire
you cannot retreat you have to keep
pushing guys otherwise your whole unit's
gonna get wiped out i legit tried i hit
up my ad agency and said we want a big
time square billboard saying twitter
protects pedophiles and they said no
they said it can't in any way be related
to that concept and i was like okay well
we'll figure something else out i would
because i would have loved to do that
that's the kind of thing that that i
want i want to i want to buck the system
using i want i want to be in their faces
i want people in times square to see us
next to coca-cola that's the point we
are telling them you are not the elites
anymore we are displacing them and we
are doing what we can to make that a
reality i just want to say one thing
about that that's like you know
using the system to buck the system
rather than trying to recreate it an
alternative system to buck that system
it's it's
and and well yeah but i mean like still
using the tool
there it's like taking the thing apart
from the inside which is how any nation
or anything else kind of collapses it's
not it's usually not just outer forces
you use the the the mechanism itself
i just think um
it is it is a complicated culture war
it is yeah you'd be if you armed a slave
rebellion with weapons from the very
empire it's rebelling against you know
they still the their empirical weapons
but
the slaves will use them to overthrow
the empire i just think you know
i i have to wonder you know it's like
there's a lot of people who want us all
to work for free and i'm like it's a
weird concept to have people who
identify as like capitalists to be like
but you should give me free stuff
you know what i mean like we we do most
of the stuff we make is free yeah but it
requires energy and time that's not free
so it's a free product for the person
most like anybody can watch this show
completely for free
you know what i mean as long as you have
an internet connection yeah well yeah i
mean like we are not charging people to
watch this live show
this is yeah this is a problem i've run
into i put every single one of my
documentaries i've done out for free but
then every time i want to make a new
documentary it's always i have to
it takes forever to try to fund again
it's a whole challenge and i don't know
if i can make another one next time so
yeah being able to fund your work makes
it continually possible but you have to
charge something
there's something we pointed out the
membership yesterday i think is
important for people to understand as
well right now we have 30 about 32 000
concurrent viewers and we are streaming
at 6
200 kilobits per second multiply that by
32 000
and that's how much kilobits is going
down
that bandwidth cost is insane
youtube's giving that to us for free
this is what people need to understand
we would not be able to do this show
without free service rumble does offer
free service but my my thing is
can we can we build up rumble's audience
by telling people on youtube about
rumble or do we just stop informing the
largest platform it's there's no simple
answer not everyone's going to be happy
i guess well let's let's uh let's read
some more
all right rose razio says i swore myself
never to do another super chat to save
money but this is important tim lydia i
implore you to get michael yan on the
show he was on jbp's podcast he went
into detail of what's in store this fall
a caveat 1 billion deaths by 2025.
uh-oh stewart just inhaled a little bit
of uh
it's good for your brachial tract i know
he inhaled the the fancy drink lauren
made it's gonna slowly work it out of
your vocal cords now
i feel better aspiration i felt like
doing that the first tip i took too it's
funny that they call it aspiration when
you breathe in liquids but they also
call being in spot you know asp
aspiration is like a thing you can have
aspirational yeah
aspergers
[Laughter]
triton says i am now a believer in tim's
fifth generational warfare hypothesis
it's obvious that the ccp is attempting
to win the hearts and minds of 75
million americans long live chicken ian
you guys saw the wikipedia change in the
definition of recession i didn't see
what they changed it wasn't that
wikipedia did it is that there was an
edit battle between people over what
recession was and then some higher
ranking wikipedia person locked it so
you couldn't change it anymore that is
the fifth generation of warfare
that there's a there's a battle over
reality and they're changing definitions
literally miriam webster changed the
definition of female to be the opposite
of male
like it's not even a definition
or true yeah if there's no definition of
male then what is the opposite of male
mean
yeah what we need to tell matt walsh to
make what is a man i think that is it
not okay i think it's kind of obvious
that there is a recession happening
right now and it does you don't have to
wait to be told like just live your life
accordingly is that but pelosi doesn't
agree oh she doesn't no okay
zek dar says the guests were so low
energy the show already sucked two tim
loves to tell everyone how they're
supposed to take a stand while always
bending the knee to youtube and giving
excuses
you know what man like
i think if anybody spent one day trying
to run this company they would be like
you're an insane person you should quit
this is nuts why would you do this
like i don't think people understand
what it takes to make all of this
possible and so um you know look i'll
read your comments and i'll read your
criticisms i i respect that but i think
that the challenge is
people don't see what it's like to you
know wake up at seven a.m and work until
midnight
monday through friday and then on
weekends that's when i get to go to the
bank and file paperwork and drop off
checks
so it's just like
it's it's it's it's
sometimes you know what's the point
is the question right
if you're going to get this many people
who are like you should be giving us the
content for free you shouldn't expect us
to pay for it you're bending the knee we
don't respect your strategies and i'm
just like
then why am i fighting for you yeah i
mean anytime you get criticisms like hey
this person that i'm not lifting a
finger to be involved with is doing
something i don't like like
okay do it then dude but the reality is
like do it yourself obviously there are
far few
haters than there are people who support
the work we're doing for sure and i
wonder what a high energy uh guest would
be
arm wrestling all right let's see
let's grab some more super chats
al says lauren i watched the whole truth
and i was honestly blown away my
question to you is if you can stay out
of the hot seat could there be more
about the stars of the right that you
interacted with that you'll put out um
the the whole truth wasn't about like
exposing people's like personal problems
or this person did that drug or this
person slept with that hooker it was
literally just about the situations i
encountered that kind of led me to be
black-built about politics and then
realizing it wasn't really about this
whole movement realizing you know people
are flawed and you can't put your faith
in man you can't put it in these other
people you have to put it in the ideas
you have to put it in god something
bigger than yourself so it's just kind
of my political journey it wasn't about
exposing the stars of the right um that
would just was something that that were
experiences i had so i don't want it to
be about who were the good guys and the
bad guys everyone loves a bit of juicy
gossip of course but that wasn't the
point of the video but i'm glad you
liked it i appreciate that also one
thing i've always made a point of is
tim i didn't talk about you in the whole
truth at all because you were just a
damn hard worker the whole time like you
were just saying you worked freaking
harder than anyone i knew during that
2016 to now period you're one of the few
people okay simping too hard but yeah i
think you earned it all i think you i
don't know i i don't know i mean like
when whenever there was like a big story
we were like
i'm gonna cover the same story you were
gonna cover like there was a similar
beat but i don't think when it came to
like working i think the reason you had
stuff to talk about with other people is
that you worked with them we never
really
like yeah we were in like the same area
i was talking about this when you like
your whole job is traveling the world
and you're like 20
it's hard to make a community so you
just kind of have these people that you
brush shoulders with that are in the
same area all the time right it's like
oh those are riots i'm gonna go there
and then you're there yeah yeah um but
yeah i definitely was more working with
this kind of
dissident right that existed and you
kind of escaped a lot of that drama
because you were doing your own thing
you truly were independent of these
movements at that time we got the
quartering he says thanks for faking the
issue last night so i could grift like a
maniac and thanks to your viewers who
tuned in everything is back to normal
now sips delicious non-descript drink
jeremy we have an event coming up that
we're planning in austin and uh we
should definitely get a bunch of coffee
brand coffee to uh serve at the event
that would be that would be really great
please send me some to the house or
something we should i want to drink it
we should figure something out so it's
like all of the attendees so i'm not
going to say too much because i don't
want to call it i don't know i don't
generate a hot seat for anybody but
there's someone i know who's got like a
burger shop in austin we're going to
have them provide the burrs if possible
and then we're playing we're planning a
live irl event so what is it i don't
want to say just yet because we're still
planning but the idea is
we would do the show on stage live for
an extended period the speakers
would be rotating guests who would come
in for about like an hour and then leave
and then we would do like a really long
show for like five hours so we'll have
and then no the idea is to bring in like
give everyone burgers okay because it's
not going to be a long event if there's
burgers
yeah people will and i know we could
have coffee brand coffee there are there
coffee brand coffee curry pods yet
make them you know what we should do we
should get uh krigler coffee and coffee
brand coffee and then you know people
can choose which one they they they oh
my gosh we'll set up a few keurigs on
the stage yeah maybe get a coffee pot in
case you want to brew some fresh french
press yeah yeah you and i love in brazil
they have these things the pow decay
show you ever have those yeah that is so
good yeah i want cheesy bread yeah it's
it's like bread with cheese in it they
bake it so it's like the bread has
cheese
in it
like it's not like the bread you open
and you can see cheese no like the
cheese is part of the flour
that's nice so my wife tried to redo it
with filo dough it's it's it's a weird
recipe too the way they make it
though
those kind of croissants that comes
apart in flakes oh yeah i'm loving all
of the super chats about uh bucko
he was like sitting on my lap he's still
out we gave him the boot he's right
outside the door waiting are you sure
guys he was when i went out there
curled up he wanted to come in here i
mean he wants to be on the show now i
think he really liked it he came in here
during the member only episode once and
everybody loved him so much he's
probably like ooh this is nice we've
been bonding he's like i don't know
what's going on here but everyone keeps
loving me yeah dave uh david
setliff says treats for the buckocast
irl bucco you're a superstar that's
right that's right
all right let's go let's let's grab some
more super chats a lot of people
pointing out states can't deport people
we have um
el galucard or lg alucard says states
can't deport people only feds can
convincing reality says tim immigration
is a federal issue states cannot deport
people out of the country this is 100
percent the right move but can the feds
give the states
like deputize them well
i don't know but if they can't then you
are i stand corrected and it is the
right move to send them to dc in new
york like let them deal with the issue
the only problem is they're not going to
deport anybody they're just like okay
fine well it's almost better keeping
them in states where you're going to
have judges that are
you know not going to be so biased
towards progressivism what if they sent
them to alaska but then the bus got lost
halfway up through canada
that would suck it's like hey got on
this bus to dc and the driver's going
like whoops i accidentally turned
towards mexico
all right liam madden says vermont's
very close election means your support
makes a huge difference to elect
congress's first auntie to party
pro-second amendment
economically populist usmc vet who led
usa's largest anti-war organization of
iraq vets
check out oh i think check out liam
madden learn more at rebirth
democracy.com
good luck man
i'm hearing that they're saying new
hampshire might go democrat for the
senate and i'm like that's crazy to me
all those free staters up there in
vermont would go democrat you got people
with flamethrowers up there they're
gonna vote to ban their own
flamethrowers all right so there's not
enough free staters in new hampshire man
okay let's see
grab some super jits
linda tarleton says first live and first
day as a tim cast member
was it's a uh
sham sahm for irl
what is that i don't do this but thank
you for being a member
all right let's see
yeah
leor engelstein says tim you reported
fake news yesterday at around 12 minutes
in your china video you said that biden
had a two-hour long conversation with
china how are we supposed to believe he
was cognizant for that long
that's a fair point
like he's like
she it's joe biden and then she's like
starts talking i have many things to say
to you joe and then just like
and then she just talks for two hours
yelling at biden
and then like finally
oh yeah okay
i don't think mine was cognizant do you
see that uh that that video where it's
like every every sentence is it's cut i
swear that's a deep fake
did you see it yet no i didn't have you
seen it
it's so honestly everybody i haven't
watched a biden video that isn't you
know atrocious to this point so like
everyone keeps coming out with all these
articles they're like oh look how funny
biden is being and i'm like
okay like that's a tuesday what there's
this we're still laughing at this this
15 second video of like four or five
different
four second clips or something like that
and his eyes are really round and like
black and they don't blink or move and
his voice sounds deep it just seems like
a deep thing benny johnson posted
something where there's there's two
bidens one buggy-eyed biden and the
other one's sleepy joe
i think i just think they're different
there's a clip from that video i think
they just pre-recorded some of them you
know what i mean like early in the
morning with his morning voice i think
the camera ones are funnier where she's
like repeatedly
going over the exact same concept
what was the predictive text generator
yeah yeah she just keeps saying the same
thing over and over again in different
creative ways and i'm like yeah holy
you're bad at this case you're supposed
to be that isn't one
bad at it i mean it seems to be working
to a certain degree they're 30 something
percent approval confused keep them
running in circles
all right
chrome leader says as a texan i agree
that what our governor is doing is not
the best tactic but our hands have been
tied at this point it's malicious
compliance
fair point fair point
all right
the kt uh kl tanker says congress should
have to pass a test on the bill
get a 85 or better than they can vote on
it you know that's it it is a good idea
but the problem is i think the system
has become too cumbersome
the issue is when you had 35 000 people
per district they could go in and
actually argue over a bill now it's 700
and what 75 000 people per district and
it's just people screaming at each other
culture totally disparate cultures
no agree or anything the more i think
about that like if i can fail a math
test in grade five and get held back a
year you should be able to fail the most
important job in the country
if you can't pass a test on what you do
come on like yeah i i'm fully an
advocate of of hitting with a felony if
they don't but like how do you guarantee
they read the bill i don't know just
like a really quick quiz i've always
thought about this for voting too like a
really quick quiz that's just like hey
what is a democrat and a republican even
just like an abcd test or like
what are the candidates on your ballot
that you're voting for and you just you
put a few fake ones in there that are
like mr magoo or whatever and if someone
guesses that their vote doesn't count
because they don't even know who the
hell they're voting for we're talking
for voters but both our politicians and
voters like there are so many things we
could do to improve the system i
understand how it would be like
i mean you're you're denying the right
to vote for idiots but
i'm i'm in favor of that let's read some
more we got manifested destiny says tim
please give a shout out to eastern
kentucky the floods have currently
killed 20 people and it's expected to
rise appalachian people had very little
and they lost what they had they need
help
yeah man sad to hear this is brutal
stuff these floods are serious
and additionally las vegas yeah now this
is crazy vegas flooding that freaked me
out like it's a desert you think there's
like
conspiracy to change the weather and
screw other countries over by flooding
them conspiracy there is a group of
people screaming that the climate is
changing harp i'm talking about like
government
what is it is cloud cloud speeding is
that what they call it where they can
actually like change the weather a bit
cloud seeding is real yeah
variety or not even they use lasers now
yeah wilhelm reich was working on that
and what what the 40s 50s oh my gosh
it's 80 year old technology yeah for
sure
i think it's so cool that we could like
attack other countries with hurricanes
yeah i hear that's what people are
telling me is that you can move
hurricanes with
i'm gonna i want to read this one from
cj diane he says tim your moral compass
is on point and your head is on straight
i don't know about your guests though
uh well they're doing all right but i
was like i did read some disparaging
comments about me i don't want to only
be disparaging someone you know gave me
some some uh credit i don't think
they're talking about you guys by the
way i couldn't be wrong no they're
scared about me i know this is important
sarah m says will of the people is on my
repeat playlist perfect song would love
to hear a cover of the mariner's revenge
song i feel like you would do it well
we have like 30 percent of a music video
done
the song we're going to be releasing
first is called only ever wanted and it
is
carter our music producer just hit this
one it's a home run for sure
i was shocked when i heard it because i
write songs like
typically right on acoustic guitar and
it's like folk rock acoustic and then he
took it the song is weirdly mostly
backwards like the instrumentation and
he made this really amazing song so
we're gonna be releasing that um
we've got a couple other songs we're
gonna be releasing as well we should
have an album coming out august 21st i
think it will have eight or nine songs
on it we do have like 30 or 40 in the
pipeline but
in this day and age i don't know if that
makes sense anymore releasing albums we
were actually thinking of just like
putting out singles when they were ready
and then i was like well
maybe we'll do that anyway but um we're
gonna have uh only ever wanted out
really soon i think maybe even in like
could be in a week or two no it's gonna
be i think in like two or three weeks
because we're finishing the music video
uh not this weekend but the next weekend
and so that's gonna be really cool i
like the idea of doing a song every time
it's ready and then when the ninth song
is done
you release an album with all nine songs
on it we could do that i was just gonna
say what some music groups are doing is
they'll record they'll release like
six or seven singles and then have a
little grace period and then an album
with like 10 or 11 songs new ones
yeah well i mean 10 or 11 songs
including that original six
so you you put out the ones as they're
coming out and then you release a full
album with a few more extra songs yeah
tool took like 17 years to put out their
newest album same with the perfect
circle oh yeah i got to read this one we
read the liam madden super chat someone
responded exactly says the lien liam
madame madden guy supports red flag laws
abortion and expanded gun control
vermonters please don't vote for him oh
it's getting spicy in the super chat all
right last one from iris with a um
i will give you a preliminary
congratulations iris as i found out
today i'm pregnant with my first child
longtime listener and member love the
show congratulations
and uh thank you for the shout out and
uh good luck best of luck
uh we'll write one more here simo libit
says put out a song every week that's
what rust did and he said it launched
his career
well it takes longer to finish the songs
we could finish a bunch of songs and
then put out one every week
um but we're also like filming music
videos for them
we
were changing the strategy a bit i
suppose
i was talking about how we had this big
plan for a bunch of the songs that was
going to follow will of the people
and for a variety of reasons we decided
to
pick different songs which have
different themes and uh different styles
i guess but uh there's one song i'm
really excited for that i think act i'm
wondering so only ever wanted
we've like showed it to people and
they've all just been like wow this is
the best song ever and i'm like probably
assuming they're just blowing smoke and
they're just saying that but i think
it's good i personally like it and it's
very different from my normal style of
songs but the song we have genocide i
think might actually end up
getting
more play because it's political
and so in this day and age like tom
mcdonald for instance
like when you hear his lyrics that means
something to you people love it so only
ever wanted is just like a typical
song
but
the song we have genocide
is actually
directly about like media manipulation
conflicts and stuff like that so i
imagine people hear the lyrics of that
one and probably get into it more we'll
see my friends if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show if you do like it you can follow us
at tim cast irl basically everywhere you
can follow me personally at tim cast and
you can support our work directly at
timcast.com with uncensored episodes of
the tim cast after hours show and new
episodes of tales from the inverted
world cast castle full episodes they're
going to be like 20 to 30 minutes long
those will be coming up soon
we're just figuring it out so thanks for
your support ben you want to shout
anything out just go to
benjoffstewart.com i'm making mini
documentary
documentary-style
news segments every single week of
everything from
lambda google's uh large language model
thing being sentient uh to anything
you'll find in the news i follow a lot
of what you do tim and just kind of take
it down a rabbit hole like an
alternative rabbit hole so if you're
into that go to benjo's stewart.com
hi lauren southern here still alive
still sober-ish
you can follow me at lauren underscore
southern or just look at my name on the
youtubes to follow my channel
i'm ian crossland lauren that was a
great call with the grand patron a
little bit of manuka honey of course
that's just a tiny bit man sweet
goodness save the bees
yeah that's the last thing i'll say bye
everyone i love you so much i will see
you next monday no actually i'll see you
next tuesday i will not be here next
monday yep we got a bit we got a big
show on monday we got a big guest coming
up i wish i was going to be here but i'm
going to take a take a weekend off and
go refresh my mind and see some family
i'm very excited love you all thank you
guys all very much for tuning in you
guys can follow me on twitter and
minds.com at sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatch let's stop me thanks for
hanging out everybody we will see you
all we're gonna have clips from the show
up on the weekend we normally do and
then we'll be back on monday thanks for
hanging out
you